with chest coms official coverage of the
2020 feat a candidates tournament
alongside me that one and only
Grandmaster Robert has Robert it's been
too long I want to say that as a fan
watching over the last couple days you
have done nothing but bring chest joy to
my face you know I didn't appreciate the
kind words it's funny because you led
with official coverage and I realized I
never once used those words official
coverage and a must have meant that I
was waiting for you to join me hey
everything that just come does is chest
coms official coverage just like this is
gonna be our official shout out to
remind it may be what is the feed a
candidates let's start rolling through
and make sure the fans know why we're
here we got to figure out who's gonna
challenge Magnus Carlsen for the next
World Chess Championship match now
taking place of course even even later
in the year than is normally seen by
chess fans normally in November we will
be looking at late December rolling into
January but of those eight phases we
have seen some amazing chess I have to
say that in my recent memory Robert I
can't remember a better start to a
candidates tournament not a single round
has gone by without at least one
decisive game and who is it gonna be
who's it gonna be at this point we'll
look at the standings here in a second
but Robert how excited have you been as
a commentator about the chess you've
been seeing on the board I've loved it
frankly the chess isn't phenomenal the
action has really been lively and we've
seen players stumble out the gates like
Dingley red only to right the ship in
round 3 we've seen players get off the
hot starts like Wang Hao by winning with
black over ding the random round one and
then drawing the next two games where's
he spoiled some chances in that second
game against the nigiri so players are
just really gearing into form they're
just the event is just taking shape we
don't really know exactly who's going to
be able to last is a very tough grueling
14 round event so a lot remains to be
seen but as of yet I've been very
impressed Dion upon machine if I'm being
honest with you yeah I think young upon
me I am along how as you already
mentioned to me have been the two in
finest form if you will not to take
anything away from Bosh a the grouts
huge win over Dingley Wren and then of
course King Lear and who many people saw
as as the the favorite if you were
ranking the two players from China did
finally get on the board
changing his score from a
to a one go nuts I guess with a big wind
that made the fans from China go nuts
over Fabiano Caruana so the the
standings are looking tight there nobody
has really found separation but as you
said still many many rounds to go 11 in
total in fact let's remind everybody the
format it's 8 players it's 14 rounds a
double round-robin the players face each
other of course with each color which is
one of the things that makes this event
special I think for the the highest
level of chess fan in terms of the
preparation we get to see what these
guys are capable of doing with so much
time not just at home in the kitchen
with all of their sous chefs but also on
the on the clock right this is a little
slower time control than some of the
events we do on chess comm from time to
time with the protest League and the
speech has championship so lots of time
to play some high quality chess and on
that note let's go through what the
pairings will be today speaking of high
quality chess I think that Fabiano
Caruana
taking on yana Pommier she is gonna be
if I had to rank a game of the day right
well we're gonna be focusing a lot
Fabiana rebounding from the rest day a
loss to Dingley rend and then playing
the man who might be playing the best
chess of anybody right now and yond upon
me ah she yeah surprisingly this matchup
is extremely rare they've only played
each other seven times in classical
chess if I'm not mistaken and yan de
palma she has won one game between the
two players so it's just frankly
shocking the it's Fenster rare matchup
but fired a car won on paper the heavy
favorite with that high rating but he
has shown a bit of shaky form here his
game against England was just
outstanding prep in terms of following
your preparation but the prep itself
left a lot to be desired and doing there
and figuring it out and so then I want
to get into that a little bit later on I
enjoyed all of your comments on this and
of course you had Vichy an on with you
who will be joining us about an hour
into the show today everybody so don't
you worry I can't wait to talk a little
bit about that because I can't wait to
ask as a fan what did you think about
certain things that Fabiano did in that
game against England Ren but let's come
back in a second talk about Dingley
Ren's game he's coming up against a nice
Giri Anisha someone who looked I mean in
round one right it was there anybody
showing maybe maybe better prep I don't
know and I tuned in obviously very early
just watching you guys and was enjoying
what I thought was going to be an
amazing game as
but then he he pushed it too far right I
almost feel like sometimes the player
who gets out prepared and has to put
their critical thinking shoes on earlier
who was young upon me ah she is black in
that game ends up coming up better in
some of these battles as Dingley rented
last game against Fabiano Caruana
yeah i mean for yong he was caught off
guard but he had a position where was
very tactical in nature so Jung was able
to wake the realist tactics figure it
out and come up with a better position
and in each Giri did not show really
precision in that game it seemed like
you know things were going his way he
was blitzing on moves and then all of a
sudden when it came to his own devices
he played a couple missteps and those
strange moves and he lost that game but
he has rebounded quite fine in those
next two games he almost lost round two
and I think almost losing that game
should help him because he's proven he
can be a stubborn defender and now let's
see him get some good positions rather
than being on the back foot
yeah a man who's had several good
positions as Maxime vache magrav will he
continue that today against Alexander
Grichuk a guy that has played pretty
solid chess
hasn't really had a lot of opportunities
maybe his his best chance was as white
against Alec Senko in round one but the
the young wild card from Russia defended
very well so I don't really would know
what to make up this matchup besides I
think right now MBL obviously one of the
tournament leaders we'll see what he can
come up with against Sasha this morning
yeah I'd be careful if I were Sasha for
sure
because he looked the most points in the
table from the first three rounds he's
one and a half with three draws but he
was better every single game he played
and Maxine for sure the reference is
third white in the first four rounds and
you know MDL is just happy to be here
but he also wants to leave his mark on
this tournament win in this game would
be huge for the turn standings I love
how you said he's just happy to be here
because he really is just happy to be
here you and I chatted with him in
different DMS when he got the wild card
nod but he promised to make to make me
his adopted son proud we'll come back to
that a little bit later finally the last
match of Wang Hao versus Alex Enco I
think if you're Wang Hao looking to
leave your mark obviously anytime
someone plays against the lowest rated
player in the event nothing against of
course Alec Senko you're kind of looking
to make a move there right with two
points out of three if Wang Hao got a
full point here that would really be
setting the tone for for his candidates
tournament yeah for long high as you say
with the white pieces you have to make
most of that he did get his only win
with the black piece isn't for Korea
like saenko speaking of stubborn
defenders his round one game it's
Alexander Grisha
when he found that a6 move fascinating
mesmerizing stuff he's shown that he is
capable of hanging with these other top
guns but it's a really difficult task
ahead and I do think they won't have us
be careful not to just going with the
mindset I must win the game that said he
is the favorite both by rating and by
the way he's playing this tournament so
that is very very key matchup for this
round and it's it'll be interesting to
talk about that a little the psychology
of feeling a little bit of self induced
pressure whether you whether you ever
feel you must win at this level maybe
those guys don't think that way I think
we look at it as an opportunity when you
look at the thing you know the stats on
paper and Wang Hao being one of the
terminal eaters at this point so anyway
all the games are ahead there we go
we've previewed the four matchups we're
about probably t-minus 90 seconds for
the from the first move being made so if
you're not following the games over on
chest comm already you should head over
there you can go to chest comm slash
events chest comm /live chest come /
Robert Hess we got to make that by the
way just what would that page entail no
one knows but I want to give a huge
shout out to already more than 4,000
people with us across numerous platforms
and we're pretty pumped to be covering
covering the biggest event of the year
to date right the world chess
championship any year that that events
happening tends to be the biggest event
but this decides what what that matchups
gonna be all about so I know we wanted
to get into a little bit more reviewing
of Game three but before we do that I
think the biggest thing to talk about
from Game three was the victory that
Dingley rent had over Fabiano Caruana
and what happened in the later stages of
that game actually leads to our daily
question so let's let's ask everybody
what they think about Wesley Soze
comments Robert was it appropriate for
Fabiano Caruana to continue playing that
game way past the point where a lot of
people expected him to I don't know what
your feelings were as a cop I was
watching you but I mean tell us now
having had a day to reflect do you
believe that Fabiano played a little bit
too long was it was it some sort of
working out the nerves or do you believe
he actually had changes for example in
this position that
we have on the board here we're from my
point of view if we're talking with a
daily question wasn't appropriate for
froggy on our trip resign at a certain
point it was more than plus five for
white and just got worse and worse were
you shocked that the American continued
to play on his black hair well it didn't
make for the best entertainment the
world but I don't think it's
disrespectful it's within their right
and Bingley Ren has to prove that he
could win and the fact that he was
spending so much time perhaps gave
Fabiano the idea that hey like if he's
gonna keep thinking he doesn't see the
clear-cut win just yet I have some
chances and event like this which five
in a car wanna has one before if he does
what he feels like is the right thing I
trust him more than I trust anybody
outside of this one off and on endure
magnus carlsen at this point so I have
no problems with it do I think it's
disrespectful maybe that's a slightly
different question I mean Bingley Ren is
the number three rate of player in the
world of course capable of handling that
game but you can't win a game that
you've already lost well as the game
continued on there was a lot of kind of
discussion about the fact that there
were no chances at this point those
following the chat over on chest comm
solved Wesley so saying push them baby
to the b-pawn but I guess I think the
main point is that it felt that the
chances just never got any any better
and of course he did resign in just a
few moments here showing everyone the
the end of the game and what it was
eventually of course Carr wanted to
throw in the towel but let us know your
opinion obviously may be disrespectful a
slightly strong word but I do think fans
were a little surprised and I think it
led to discussion of or is he working
out nerves or like Robert said did he
trust that hey as long as that white
king had a little bit of air around him
there's always a chance to blunder and
he wanted to play on so give us your
opinion get involved on social media use
the official hashtag of the event feed
eight candidates you can also use
hashtag chess TV we tend to follow that
and without any further ado those we can
see on the right side the games are
getting underway all four games have had
at least one move played Robert any
anything catch your fancy first we'll go
to ding Lee runs game with a nice Giri
because at least it has two moves on the
board at this point I like your logic
and how you games makes a lot of sense
to me honestly a choice between two and
one go for the bigger quantity so well
yes if I'm surprised by anything No
but it that remains to be seen because
the surprises tend to happen around move
eight in these top-level games because
theory is so well trodden that they're
not shopping anybody just yellow you
could say five in a car one is round one
game even I move for when you an f3 for
the semen that was surprising to many
well the only maybe shock on the board
is that one of these games has an e4
move although I think Ray Robson might
be teasing a little bit hanging out with
us in the chat there shout-out to
Grandmaster Ray Robson known as the
spicy caterpillar over on chest comm we
do have one e4 played in the game
between Maxine Bosh a magrav and
Alexander grishnack of course over Lopez
I would say is never a surprise when
when Maxime is is playing the white
pieces although hey we have a Berlin I I
said in my video analysis of MBL's game
versus Dingley red that no one plays the
Berlin against against MBL anymore guess
who guess who defies that Alexander
Grisha going for a mainline Berlin right
now it looks like on the board well you
asked me about surprising openings and
seeing of Berlin in a super grandmaster
game is really one of the biggest
surprises a guy could ask for so thank
you to Andy and Sasha Gousha before that
a little bit of sarcasm there I don't
mean you you know sarcasm is not always
in your humor playbook but what I said
only on weekends and it is a Saturday
right so it is a Saturday right and we
had someone say earlier Danny and Robert
hanging out on a Saturday could it get
any better and then he put in
parenthesis my life is really sad
so right now unfortunately let's review
what the Berlin is I'll do my best to
make it exciting in the sense that this
is a mainline variation of the Marie
Lopez that has some of the most forcing
and in-depth preparation especially by
one MBO
often with both colors as any variation
he plays so the main point is of course
as the centre opens up we get a lot of
forcing exchanges and to set the tone of
what this structure is all about you
have a four-on-three for white
trying to take advantage of what is a
double pawn structure or bench lead down
the road
Black has the two bishops si as a form
of dynamic compensation but really a lot
a lot tells us about where this where
this type of Berlin's gonna go over the
next few moves White has a couple ideas
you can you can bring the bishop to F
for in some critical variations often
the idea of h3 to have that sort of
escaping escape route and eventually you
can kind of make some tricks dynamic in
the center with the bishop on this
diagonal trying to open it up the other
way that the position has been played
classically is a sort of a more slower
slower dance on the Queen side King e8 a
very flexible move by black you're kind
of keeping all your options open also
over protecting the f7 pawn against
future tactics so I'm gonna hold my
breath I'm excited I'm joining you for
the first time in the feed a candidates
live coverage right you can notice I'm a
little bit more of the young gun here
Roberts like a ho oh yeah I'm like we
can't breath on the openings here
considering we've in lives I with chest
moves played for five minutes you've
spoken about more chest in last five
minutes I think you've done in the past
five shows you've done together so Danny
I'm the one cracking jokes you're the
one talking just what is going on I
don't know but okay h5 played with
Bishop h4 sorry Bishop before now this
is the line that has become a little
more topical on part of the idea of
black playing h5 and sliding the King to
e8 is you can't really play these lines
with h5 where you're trying to prevent
and slow down a g4 advance without
worrying about the g5 square so for
reading into the advanced prep the the
footwork these guys are doing King e8 is
often designed for black to play the
extended h5 lines because you can't
otherwise do so without f7 becoming a
problem relaxed idea from here is he's
hoping that by slowing down White's pawn
advance this is a little more a little
more worrisome now because you'd be
opening up variations sorry opening up
lines for blacks pieces this is gonna
leave white to have to figure out
usually something else often white will
will will switch to a central plan and
try to punch through e6 as I highlighted
with the bishop here so again this
position has been played many times a
lot of theory ahead so what does your
great setup of this opening is that h5
also gives the h6 square to the black
rook and it looks like best scores not
free but there are moments where the rug
does indeed slide up to h6 is actually
plenty of lines with that in fact and
white
as you mentioned as the four-on-three on
the kingside and you would love to
mobilize those pawns get one on f4 the
other one on g4 it's our pushing with
the board but White has a lot of trouble
because of this h5 move as you point out
so a lot left to determine how this game
will go I know that sounds weird because
I already move 11 but black here has
some flexibility of do I play Bishop e7
there it is you could have started with
Bishop e6 first now that black has
played Bishop e7 white simply goes rook
a to d1 and then decides well my going
over F to e1 and just take control of
the two central files or is black gonna
end up going Bishop e6 rook da type
stuff trading material and because
blacks four-on-three on the Queen side
isn't a true majority because the double
pawns hard to create a passed pawn and
you have double pawns that means that
white when pieces get trade off the
board it's favorable for the side with
the undone construction and that that
very well explained a reason for the the
imbalance here it's kind of why you see
the position is evaluated is very very
close to equal both sides have different
things they're playing for which despite
the poking at the Berlin I think that a
lot of people do and you know for a good
reason that it's it's been so
well-prepared and leads to a lot of
draws because people know it so well it
does continue to offer chances for both
sides because both sides want different
things so you do see it at the highest
level still trying to find some way that
they're gonna say to the other you know
I know this position or I've prepared it
a little bit better than you and I think
I have a new idea to try so we'll see if
that that's something that one of them
come up with speaking of what the
players want to come up with we're in
the opening stages as we work through
each game and set the tone for the
battles that will be round four let's
remind everybody and meet the players
real quick one at a time MPL this guy
was the the late the late joined to the
feed a candidates party after came over
job off dropped out of the event at the
last minute but a lot of fans of course
very excited and we know that Maxime is
a very well deserving potential
candidate for the World Championship
title you can see a list a list that is
long of his accomplishments but maybe
not even quite as long as the list that
Alexander grishnack brings to the table
this guy this guy was my kind of like
Dark Horse as like a surprise pick that
no one talks about cuz he's kind of been
here for so long but he's still
they're at the middle of pack only a
half a point behind the leaders I'm
excited to see what what Grisha comes up
with as the event moves on I would say
South Shore in many ways the people's
champion because they love themselves
some soccer strip he's always up for a
little bit of light humor he is very
sharp tactically and he's always in time
trouble so he's a lot of fun to watch on
the board also very stressful but also
off the board he's a great person and he
really enjoys just bringing chest masses
and having a good time while doing so
and Danny I also want to say one thing
about these two players in particular is
that Alexandra shook he used a lot of
time except for this game clearly and
Mexico sure the crowd is more
predictable with his opening repertoire
and we talked with visi about that the
other day that in some ways that's very
good because he knows it very well but
the other hand is easier for him to
prepare for him because you know it
should weren't again you said hey Maxine
Berlin and you said it you know kind of
jokingly but you also have a lot of
seriousness behind it
mexi plays this time and time again yep
no and people and Chad have been
observing I've been watching chefs TV
chat YouTube twitch we're watching all
of you guys sorry if we don't always
call out your comments or questions but
please keep them coming
people have been observing griffix time
management because there was even a
threat on on reddit this week people
talking about why does grishnak take so
much time in the opening well we can
talk about the different personalities
and and sometimes it can be a bad habit
he has but here here that's not gonna be
a debate right because he did Nomex
seems gonna play e4 he knew he could get
a Berlin if he wanted it so clearly
Grichuk is bringing some type of prep to
the table here we are already on move 18
and both players have more time than
they started with so all right well
circle back here the the tone has been
set for a Berlin it's gonna be a dynamic
one I think white is kind of all-in
right now even allowing his Queen side
to be worse than than blacks Queen side
which is saying something in a Berlin
but that's because he's been able to
accelerate and break through and maybe
try to use his three on to majority over
here so well keep an eye on this one I
want to go to the game that is second
furthest along if that's okay with you
Robert and that's Fabiano Caruana versus
yonder Pompeii she and and see what
these two guys are gonna give us in a
grünfeld where right now white just a
teeny advantage as you kind of always
have when you get a big Center and
and then learn and then show everyone
how to use it you'll be back up and see
how we got here yeah we should do that
and then I'll make a point as you know
we go through the moose first that's a
rare situation for Fabiana let's be on
the white side of this position in fact
is he's only had this ten years ago as
Peter dockers is informing me and that
just goes to show that he's bringing
back he's reviving some of his old
repertoire for this candidates
tournament so he is not somebody that
it's easy to prepare for it's funny cuz
well you could say he's bring him back
and he's an he's pushing new boundaries
right you mentioned the four of three
Neuman so he played against alec Senko
and and played it very well right I
joked that he said in the official
interviews after the game that hey this
is the first time I played this position
I kind of thought I'd see what happens
but he's being casual about the fact
that he doesn't play positions for the
first time that he doesn't feel very
confident in terms of what him and his
team worked on and he executed so we'll
see what he does here right he's
obviously going for an opening he hasn't
played in a very long time set the tone
here for this Grunfeld Robert what are
both sides playing for here over the
next few moves yeah and I actually want
to go back just before this Queenie to
move was played for a quick second
because many people might be wondering
aren't there two pieces attacking the
pawn on c5 and only one pawn for black
defending it so it does feel like hey
didn't miss an opportunity just steal
upon when it comes to these group outs
you're central mass for white those D
and E for pawns are so important that
even winning upon D take c5 isn't always
the ideal solution because after D takes
d5 black was Queen c7 and says take on
b6 while you're at it I'll take eight
takes b6 and look at my work on a e8
Queen on c7 they have to open files to
work with the Bishop g7 is the full
scope of the diagonal and the bishop on
c4 is in harm's way along that C file so
it's blacks gets ample compensation for
that sacrifice on and that's why if I'm
going to keeps obsession more close and
says hey I would like that D and E for
pawn situation I'm not going decide what
to do with those pawns just yet and it's
a good lesson I guess because you know
for those who don't play a grünfeld the
battle the battle that that the tone
that is set immediately whenever black
goes for the line is look I'm going to
give you
Center so that I have something to
attack for the rest of the game but but
it's almost White's chess moral
responsibility to challenge that most of
the main line theory is always going to
be white playing for positions like this
and saying well chess principles I think
went out a lot of the time if I get a
big center and that space advantage
allows my pieces to be better and
restrict your mobility this is kind of
kind of what I need to do in this
structure rather than settling on this
pawn and bringing your pieces to life so
okay that I can't wait to see where this
goes especially as we continue to get
word from Peter docker shout out to the
whole team working super hard behind the
scenes to bring you the chess calm news
reports all the chess calm analysis we
give you breaking into these the game
within the game so to speak some of
these games really revealed what these
guys are working on at home which for
super chefs fans is interesting let's
remind everybody who's not a super chess
fan who these guys are with every game
Robert Viviano Caruana at one time at
one time was sporting a 70s look and
mustache and outfit there what do you
think yeah I was gonna comment on his
attire but yeah it is pretty good call
about that but look at his list of
accomplishments they really speak for
themselves at this point he was the
challengers to twelve twenty eighteen
World Chess Championship took on Magnus
Carlsen twelve straight draws lost in
the tiebreaks wrapping in blitz quicker
time controls not his specialty and on
the flip side of this matchup jana Palma
she doesn't have the classical chess
success that I'm gonna Caruana does but
is known as quite a speed demon so Danny
when you see these two competitors what
do you make of a matchup like this first
thing observed is that that was from
Tata Steel two years ago where we caught
that video we've had the official
coverage with our partners there for a
while and why Kenzie but that was before
yellen's man bun so shout out to that
throwback haircut but you know I think
it's interesting because Jana pom Yoshi
and and Fabiano car want to have very
different styles I think Fabiano known
is a little more I guess well you would
say like deliberate more measured I
guess in his approach to some positions
I think Yan can be a wild card at times
because he's a super talent maybe one of
the most talented guys in his generation
but sometimes sometimes Vichy and on
said when he joined the show after after
Yan got that win in round 1 or over
nigiri sometimes he can be a little bit
unpredictable too right and I think that
Fabiano's kind of anything but
unpredictable I guess he's played some
openings we didn't see coming but
overall I think Fabiano is he's he's
someone who we kind of know what we're
gonna get he's the second best chess
player in the world as far as most
things go for the last five six years of
behind Magnus Carlsen and you know what
what he's gonna do with the white pieces
here against you on the tournament
leader
I'm interested to see so we'll keep
we'll keep our eyes on it
that's a good shout out as we talk about
Fabiana who was the last challenger to
the World Chess Championship that's what
this event is all about is who's gonna
be next some of these games are really
going slow here particularly the Wang
Hao Alex anko game not many moves on
that board if we want to take a look at
her do you want to go to daily run any
Fury no I think we can go to Wang Hao
Alex anko and I was going to say that
Alexei Coe in some ways has become the
second coming of Alexander Grichuk and
he is a massive time trouble throughout
his games his game against John DePalma
XI in round three became very tactical
in nature gorilla Alexei no had a
brilliant exchange sacrifice he gave his
rook and had an extra Bishop for that
rook but he could have sacrificed him g6
with a nice tactical blow but he had
three four minutes left and said I
couldn't think everything through at
that point so Alex anko has this calm
deliberate manner to his plane and he's
also has that kind of solid style so
it's nobody's trying to come up with a
perfect configuration at all times I'm
not entirely sure I did play him at the
feed a chess like on grants whist the
Isle of Man 2099 I keep taking credit
for the reason that he's here because I
was the first person he dispatched on
his way to becoming the wild card well
you didn't win that event actually it's
funny you mention it now because his
opponent played in that event I feel
like this is like one of those you know
six shades of Kevin Bacon or something
three degrees of Robert has I bet we
connect every chess player in the world
to Robert has through some version of a
victory or a loss you want to take me up
on that
you mean normally a victory up from them
so no but Robert you you mentioned the
loss you had to lxn KO you played very
well at the at the feet eh that's not
congruent suppose I'll just say that
even if you won't but Wang Hao won that
event that's why he's here Alex anko got
the wild card from the organizers let's
remind everybody else how we got here
and review the
opening real quick take a look at how
these guys decided to come out of the
gates here we have not not a mainline
opening kind of the opposite of or put
it this way
not a end in depth and very well known
Road and that we're seeing between 500
Caruana and Yana pom Yoshi and then of
course MBL versus grish ik this is a
slightly more unique move order
eventually transposes into a queen spawn
game with a sort of delayed kind of Slav
slash Grunfeld kind of structure night
BD 2 played in these types of positions
I've actually played some of these
positions and just quickly made a move
like Knight c3 and not realised after D
takes e4 how hard it can be to get this
pawn back in some of these structures so
you have to be a little careful normally
in a Queen's Gambit you think I can
always give up that pawn and get a big
center but here often white will go for
Knight bTW to overprotect the pawn and
from d2 sometimes you go for plans like
this that involve a delayed break
through here with e4 coming so black has
played a 5 and b3 is where we currently
stand now kind of a ready looking
structure whites playing over the next
few moves if you gave it to them
something like Bishop e2 something like
maybe putting a knight on e5 eventually
trying to go for e4 house black
approaching these positions with with
the different tension that's building in
the pawns and knowing that a 5 is gonna
be a harder breakthrough in the center
to get then White's corresponding e for
Robert yeah black you'll not be able to
e5 in but can prevent a forward Bishop
f5 at some moment and the critical ideas
involve some combination of black
playing pawn a 5 to 8 for who try to
create some tension on the Queen side or
more tension already exist from the
seafloor d5 squares and then playing
ideas like Knight e4 Knight B to d7 and
things of that nature so 94 it has the
benefit of opening up the Bishop of the
long diagonal and you can't play e4
finite sitting on that square so that's
blacks idea white on the flip side can
play Bishop b2 as you mentioned but
Bishop a3 is also a potential other
Square to go to and if you played Bishop
f5 is black by putting your Bishop on
that Square my knight can go to h4 or it
attacks your bishop away from that f5
Square and it causes my knight too
the room of the board which I don't like
but it does open up my bishop on the
fianchetto diagonal so it's kind of a
mixed bag in these positions I've had
them many many many times in online
blitz games so we talked about these
players taking their time in the opening
stages this reminds me of a large number
of 3-minute blitz games I've played on
chess comm so we could have had this
position blitz down instead there
they're just trying to feel each other
out see what you know what they're
attending here is black going to play
for an eventual 94 or play a four what
what idea is a let's ankle looking for
in for it same can be asked of one cow
yeah and of course we're setting the
tone a little bit with some basic
descriptions for for everyone tuning in
if just where people can put their
pieces what the basic ideas might be and
of course this position has has been
played many times and for those who have
databases and are curious to look into
theory as Robert said not only has he
played it many times on chess calm but
it's been played by many others and I
think some people wonder like well then
why do they spend so much time in these
early stages well part of that is you
know they've got so many things going on
in their head in terms of preparation
before these events they look at these
types of positions and sometimes as you
know deep is in into the 20s and 30s
they want to make sure that they don't
make a slight misstep now and then 10
moves from I realize I know that wasn't
exactly the line I was trying to play
right we're gonna talk a little bit
about that of course as we see some of
these games head into the middle game
you start to see some of the preparation
revealed but it's not always known that
someone forgot a line Robert until like
several moves later all of a sudden you
know they say after the game you hear
them I forgot my prep right and and that
happens with just like a subtle move
right here that's why they slow down and
sometimes take their time and let's slow
down remind everybody who these guys are
we've been doing they with every game
Wong how is the guy that won the chess
calm feed a grand swiss robert hess was
there some would say that Robert has
gave him the luck to be here I know yeah
nobody has said that except for long I
may not agree with that given his
skeptical look based on what I'm saying
but okay no this guy is so far he's been
the best player from China in the event
there are two of them and and he's shown
to be in a little better form
he's been outspoken about the fact that
not even sure the tournament should have
taken place but being there right now he
looks to be playing some of the best
chess / overall of anybody in the event
and we'll see if that can continue his
opponent the young career aleck senko
made sure made sure in the the pre event
kind of opening ceremony press
conference he was there with a lot of
the organizers Arkady dvorkovich the PTO
president he said look I'm here to win
the event I'm not just happy to be here
and then some people in the stands kind
of laughed at that well this shouldn't
have been so many people in the stands
for most of those events so great that
was problematic to begin with but
critics anko is very talented
whether he's ready for a stage like this
is a totally different question but
Alexi anko kind of hopped in the scene
he was Peter Svidler second and I don't
know if this is the case but I was
joking the other day that maybe the
roles have been reversed when the you
know the pupil becomes the the star and
maybe Peter Svidler is working for Lex I
have no know you know when you were my
pupil so long ago but I don't remember
that we've talked this many times you've
been upset many times because I always
have the same response you know we all
black out things from our childhood that
are traumatic and we don't want to
remember so you know I'm not surprised I
don't want to block out Dingley Reds
game because we finally have some action
after being the slowest the slowest
opening out of the gates everybody
Dingley renin a nice giri have a blitzed
out a few moves and the position is is
getting spicy getting spicy here let's
back up and see what the last you moves
were in the opening and and see how we
got here it's a Catalan but it's also
becoming in an open Catalan very quickly
here tell me when you want to stop
Robert I'm going through the moves we
had the bishop before early check and
now a5 yep this is this is a fun line
black of course has other options when
the bishop comes to d2 sometimes you can
even backup the Bishop d7 but a5 one of
the most challenging approaches then you
get d5 after castles and c5 these
positions are very very aggressive and
sharp and we get exchanges here with
Queen to b6 tempering the knight on d4
your thoughts on the type of line we're
about to see and sue here well for an
itch this is I'm caught by surprised
with his opening I don't know if that
means ding the rent is as well because
ding the rent
furnished for months on end but this is
a very kind of strategically awkward
line if you're looking from the
perspective of the black side because
then you see this night on before it's
under attack right now
but little bit black already committing
on the queenside you plead upon to a
five which means that the b v square is
one that i would like to use if the time
is right the whites temporarily up upon
because i've captured on d5 and you have
not captured back but the pressing
question at the moment is what do I do
about my night under attack on d4 to me
III looks like the move just protecting
that night and when black recaptures on
d5 say with the pollen you're left with
an isolated pawn and what is the dynamic
of an isolated pawn it means that it's
harder to protect cuz you don't have its
best buddy another pawn to safeguard it
but you have the two adjacent files open
for your pieces so the C file or work
tool and there the e-file for work to
land there and you just operate around
that pond source warming and getting
activity in that manner so Knight takes
d5 instead of pawn takes d5 and we're
just going to go back after e3 then
you're saying well I've recaptured the
palm block compromising my pawn
structure but look at that bishop on C
not a very happy piece behind the pawn
on e6 yeah why could castle in a
position like this and then continue
developing you already highlighted the b
v square as a problem at some point
maybe down the road yeah you know going
back to what you highlighted about the
isolated Queen pawn I think it's
interesting to say that normally when
you have that not just the open files
but as you said that kind of squares
you'd like to dance on maybe those
squares aren't as easy to access as you
might normally have in an i QP and that
kind of gives white a little bit more of
an edge than you might you might see it
is it is a structure you anticipate to
get whenever you play C 5 this is kind
of a tirage you know structure if you
will not not exactly that opening it
came from a Queen's Indian or Catalan
move order but often you do get one side
strapped with an isolated pawn the
question is what are you getting for it
and I don't think you're wrong kind of
drawing attention to the fact that it
may be ding mere M wasn't expecting this
line for Manish given the time that he's
already taken here right it's not okay
now he's played e3
a ton of time but he's clearly showing
that he doesn't wasn't as expecting this
at least it's not as as much as a niche
was who still has more time than he
started with with with over over 100
minutes on the clock
Danny I'm getting word from Peter
Dockers and thanks again to Peter who's
reading all the great recaps so you
should go chess accomplished news to
check those out as well but he's telling
me that ding the Ren only faces a 5 move
on move for one time that he found in
the database those from 2015 and for
Geary he's only played the BOGO Indian
one time and that was in Dortmund 2011
so I got it was like how old is him and
he still looks like he's 5 years old I
mean was he a newborn then wow yeah he
was he was a young pup himself and she
got the Peter for giving that
information but it goes to show that
these players are really making
themselves hard to peg down you cannot
expect this opening from either of them
and yet here we are
BOGO Indian defined as this bishop
before check by the way everybody and
then this a5 variation that follows it
as Peter dockers said is something that
Dingley rent has almost never faced in
his career which is crazy when you think
of a guy like ting li Ren let's meet him
remind everybody of his pedigree he's
faced a lot but apparently this opening
from a nice gear he does have him a
little surprised right now a lot of
people talking about ding as uh as being
maybe if you had to pick somebody who
wasn't Fabiano Caruana as the as the
favored to win the whole event a lot of
odds were pointing his way although he
started out Owen too and has not really
been in his best form at this point in
the event but then again neither has his
opponent uh nigiri who may be finding
himself a little bit as you said he's
he's held some tough positions so maybe
he's in better shape than his overall
score would indicate Robert but uh your
thoughts on these two guys here and and
the big matchup we're about to see well
Anish is clearly still his usual self
because he's posting on social media
just by being in the midst of perhaps
the most important chess tournament of
his life and that could be a good sign
that he's in good spirits he'd lost that
first game where frankly Jana palm-tree
played an excellent game so credit to
young for that victory and this
nothing like having two whites in a row
to come back from a tough start dangler
and start with two losses he beat
Fabiano Caruana in round three with the
white pieces and now he gets the white
piece against a nice giri on paper that
should be a very favorable matchup for
the number three player in the world and
I'm one rated player from China but of
course in any single game it's tough and
onigiri is shown good preparation he's
playing a line that he has not played
since 2011 and now we're already in
unique territory where both sides are
just trying to figure out over the board
rather than relying on extensive home
preparation
yeah and I'm I'm always curious when
players of this level start start taking
the time they do I mean Dingley rent
hasn't played the position many times as
Peter said but will that lead to a
unique an interesting original plan that
a nice Giri doesn't see coming or maybe
maybe a tough start to his middle game
so we're gonna take a very very quick
break we've we've set the tone all four
games are rocking and rolling you can
head over to chess calm / events or our
live server to follow them directly but
don't go anywhere
Robin and I are gonna be right back as
some of these games are heading to the
middle game feed a candidates coverage
here on chef's comm continues in just a
few minutes
[Music]
and we are back now joined by the one
and only
Vishwanath on Anand joining us time to
check in with the champ as we like to
say Vichy can I just say as a fan over
the last few days I've been I'm in chess
heaven watching your analysis and thank
you so much for being a part of our
coverage thanks so much
well we we talked a little bit just now
off-camera about about every game having
a little bit of something interesting to
talk about let's jump into Fabiano's
game here versus the pump Yoshi and give
us your thoughts on the fact that Bobby
played this Grunfeld for the first time
in a long time in his career according
to to kind of our our review and the
position on the boards getting a little
spicy with the H pond running up your
thoughts on where we stand right here
well this is this new alpha0 world where
if you can't think of a plan you just
roll the hitch phone up and see where it
goes and the thing is here hit six black
can play Bishop a fade whereas in a
surprising number of games black is
isn't in time and has this bishop on a
check and then it's that way he covers
the g7 square well staying around but
the beauty of this is that it's
long-term even if white were to take up
on g6 things can happen on the kingside
rather slowly so in both cases despite
the fact that we're trading a lot of
pieces it's quite a lot of energy left
in the position you mentioned this idea
of being long term are you referring to
the fact of whether you take on g6 or
even if you play h6 even if there's
nothing immediately delivered black
basically has long term things to
constantly be worried about let's say
the pollen does arrive on h6 and there's
always this outside idea of a mating net
is this kind of what you're referring to
is like this alpha zero idea of brushing
the h bone up the board and see what see
if it can pay dividends down the road
yeah very much putting the bottom hit
cigs and I think especially in the
French there's been some majestic games
where white just puts a bomb in at six
and then with impositions with four
rooks white drops pawns left right
just to get to the seventh and then the
attack explodes I mean just random games
that I would have to look up but clearly
Yanis has some something in mind because
he's swapping down and I don't know how
to evaluate this yet I would say still
white tends to have quite some playing
these end games but the pond hit six is
an extra detail I mean you can lose it
and clearly the question of make doesn't
arise anymore but it is a lot of space
and avoid can do something with these
central pawns then you can still be
better fishing my hunch right now is
this is probably equal we will say I was
gonna ask you a question vishay so h6
was playing and black had put Quincy
eight given the opportunity to swap
Queens so what is it about the queen
capture that neither side has one to do
just yet because white could have led
with Queen sexy a check before playing
h6 and black could have played Queen
sexy one check before playing Bishop
retreat to f8 so are they just jockeying
for position on the Queen side or what's
that dynamic like with detention of the
Queen's going so far I'm not a big
expert in the grünfeld but I'm going to
wager that if white wants to play d5
here then it helps that the bishop will
not be already on c8 because then you
could just play six but as if here I
play d5 and we see one Bishop c1 and
then sorry
d5 I misheard you yeah spoke and then v6
then if I take and you take with the
little bit weak so that that could be an
idea of the thing is if you like Ana
spawned in my knight can sit very
comfortably on g5 later so there are
some ideas like that if I after d5
if you play e6 then I could take and if
you take with the Queen then maybe a
Queen c7 gives some sort of initiative I
don't know now this Queen d6 so I'll
need to flesh this out a bit but I guess
that's why why it's delaying it
that's why black didn't do it because no
black black bishop afraid without so
that he would be defiled e6 and
presumably white is gonna move something
now and say move step away
I'm sorry bishop well considering we're
in a novel territory I believe this is a
new position pure Dockers had told me
that there was some horse game from the
80s that was played before Queen c8
being the first new move according to
what he told me so I you know can't
fault you for not knowing me you know
every single intricacy of this line it
was just curious to me how the players
are determining whether or not to
capture on c8 55 is indeed the option
that certainly makes sense that you
would not capture on c8 because e 6 is
going to be the response natural one at
that that black is trying to get off yes
also if white plays d5 black often wants
to play e5 himself and then play Bishop
d6 + f6 so it's not really the e6 Theory
motive but I think black doesn't want to
recapture on e6 with a pawn that seems
to me can end up unpleasant for black so
right so that's why he is not raiding
Queens yet did fabio I defy no he's
thinking so let's see when he comes up
with actually he doesn't have an easy
choice because playing maxi force
available right official basics even so
maybe Knight c3 maybe 93 93 and if
Knight to c4 you can what are we are we
say somewhere g5 yeah
yep that that makes sense to me and one
other question I'm having is so black
always wants to meet d5 with east six so
white probably doesn't want to play d5
because if well they do you do want to
play it so let me rephrase the question
but you know that black is going to play
e6 but if black plays d6 to prevent d5
then you're happy your pawns on d4 is
that correct because then the bishop on
b7 lacks any useful diagonal because it
can no longer go to see it and get
anywhere into the game I remind miss
reading this situation without rooks and
without major pieces it's a different
dynamic I mean black may not need to go
very far right black would want to do is
to play a5 Bishop c6 b 5 a 4 as soon as
possible
and white really needs to do something
in the center so I was gonna say is
there any way like to the track place
with white but I'm not completely sure
what I can do about Bishop a six so I
might see four right the the idea of
Bishop h6 is maybe even even more
effective than night c4 right away on
nice III it's a good point and to
highlight some of the lines Robert and
Bishop been saying everyone the reason
d5 e6 is a no brainer is because if you
try to trade first and then take black
taking back with the bishop here is
instantly probably a better end game for
black with two bishops and the the
two-on-one potential passed pawn coming
here to the Queen side so is it is there
any merit to that ok d5 has been played
so obviously there's still an
opportunity for a queen trade but I was
saying is there any merit to the fact
that if black plays e6 now right so
there's a choice to trade first but if
you but if you play u6 now is there any
merit now that you have this pawn on h6
to trying to keep the Queen's on the
board at this point I know moving the
Queen off probably allows Knight c4 but
is there would you consider Knight c3
more of an option just because of
keeping the Queen's on the board is
there is there any outside chances of a
King side attack or at this point is
that just kind of kind of silly no I
actually
I was considering it even in the quintic
say it should see a like see three okay
and if you take obviously I take on d5
and I'm threatening land on f6 I don't
want to do that so if you don't take and
you play Knight p7 I think might be five
you might already be talking a pawn yeah
and this pan steeple I mean the diamond
having the pawn on d5 is one advantage
and it's quite typical of the variation
that divides Blackwell to c6 square
right so well for me it's starting to
look a bit a something like this it's
starting to feel a bit thin but I don't
small yeah yeah he did play six I was
gonna ask whether you when you're
preparing for events like this I mean
never prepared at the level obviously of
someone like yourself or any of these
guys but there's there's both the
concrete preparation of trying to get an
exact idea but there's also the
preparation of going for the type of
position you've analyzed or or saying
hey I think if I get this type of
structure I have good long-term winning
chances right you what do you think
about the chances Fabiano had something
like this in mind as far as you know I
know if I get this pawn on h6 and these
types of grünfeld end games with a pawn
on d5 I still have decent winning
chances because of X Y or Z do you think
there's a chance Bobby is still kind of
in some preparation here I don't think
you can cover everything as we saw in is
simply too much there's always things
that you have but you do some general
work you see typical games in these
positions because if you dropped into it
you shouldn't be working things out of
the bone you should have some idea of
how the nuances here work right so I
guess he might have studied typical
games he may well have known hot game he
may have studied typical games he may
have seen similar positions and
sometimes even when you have a position
you're happy with you probably want to
execute five or ten moves on the board
just to you know play around and see
what develops because it gives you a
better sense of how the middle game is
going to come around this she let me ask
you a question here you know for Fabiano
do you think he's taking both his
previous game and his opponent in mind
when choosing this opening because when
I see an end game between these two
players and one slightly better for
white I do feel like this suits Fabiano
style more than it does Yan so how much
does that weigh in a player's thought on
preparing for a game of this magnitude
and there are very typical ones where
white swaps one pair of ropes wide swaps
both pairs whether you get defy whether
you can defy ban 90 for these sort of
things I've been the young knows this
end game as well quite well and my
understanding is that he's getting he's
getting there on time
but yeah I mean he's got me six on time
and I don't even really see what it
should do but let's say Queen say three
Queens see eight bishops a 93 is a place
to start looking
still I mean is it is it fair to say
it's it's still a three result position
I mean because if white plays to
aggressively there's always the chance
that the the two-on-one long term for
black ends up being a little more
dangerous than what white has with d5 or
even this is more to result they're
probably only white can win I think for
the moment there isn't too high a chance
there's a higher chance of black being
worse than white right
but long-term black does have a queen
second majority and that power at six
could suddenly come back to haunt you
right Mike waited to defend it forever
so that's a factor to keep in mind the
timing worked out well for Yann right he
played the rook to c8 in time to make
sure he could get the bishop to f8 which
is kind of a key point
that you said that indicative that he
knows the line he understands he doesn't
want the bishop stuck on h8 because in
positions like this you know the h6 pawn
is not only target but the bishop is
probably better pointing towards the
Queen side so I'm getting the sense you
feel like Yan should be just fine here
and this because if I participate in the
game anymore
right that's on the fake it's keeping an
eye on head six for the end game you can
play six and it just seems to be in good
shape
okay all right well he's played a nice
c3 so I'm I'm excited about that because
I wanted to keep the Queen's on the
board you know that's just because I
liver for an unsound checkmate attack so
keeping the Queen's on the board is up
my alley
and but what do you think now I mean so
there's nice c4 there's bishop basics
but there is the point that it's gonna
be a little bit more dynamic than those
end games we saw coming with the idea
that you know this h6 you and I you and
I were talking about the alpha zero sort
of novelties it's contributions to the
chess world when we when we had dinner
in st. Louis and you talked about the
fact that we learned that just rushing
the H pawn up the board even if you
don't even think about you can ask
questions later eventually eventually
there's ideas that the King has to worry
about and and this is is this may be
some reason to keep the Queens on the
board for Fabi just to make it a little
bit harder for Yan to ever kind of rest
easy that there may be an outside mating
attack well that's the big name didn't
really try to keep the Queens from the
board it's just he's he's been playing
both of it he's been saying you want to
take on c1 that's fine but as long as
you don't have something else in 93 I
was just getting her to think about it
and if he file then I want to play a
text effect really but then I have
access to open square mighty form right
and f6 yeah
potentially an f6 so if I can do
something without a d5 that would be
better so one thing is could eco Bishop
b4 so you say why as I should be for and
and maybe the Queen comes over here the
King side is that an idea yeah so Bishop
default
most and then the question is if Bishop
did for what can I do I can take on d5
maybe I don't know I'm getting excited
about ideas like queena for and yeah oh
not right away so I can't actually
instead of each takes d5 your idea is
right Danny just wrong executed Queen g5
means that you can't take on c3 twice
because Queen D is checkmate as well you
see what happens when you always have
checkmate on the brain eventually it
works out well but this is precisely the
sort of thing that hit six is supposed
to allow you to do it it gives you some
right space so well I mean I wish it
before but something maybe Bishop as a
knight c4 here's it's a good time to do
this nicéphore because if you go we
should be for every five five right and
so the question is what you want to do
instead how can I sleep for are you
going to just wake with Bishop g5 so one
of the ideas once the pawn comes to e5
though is that this this d5 is is now a
protected pass or it's stable are there
ideas where you can you know somehow
Trey I know you'd be sacrificing the
bishop pair but I started thinking of
like Knight be five or something where I
give up the d4 Bishop for the c4 Knight
and I'm and I'm left with this powerful
past D pawn heading into the endgame you
think maybe that's that's an idea i mean
ii v i don't know it's might be a 6 1997
no but yes and then I go Queen 884 19 no
sorry instead of a six in which line if
you go back just a night see phone you
wanted to go Bishop d4 right on nice c4
I I played Bishop d4 yeah
and I play d5 UN might be five if I only
takes d4 you have to take with the Queen
right so if you can just get that up you
fight
maybe five yep we've got three takes
before you have to take with the Queen
Queen takes Queen takes here sorry Queen
takes e4 I mean yeah for black and then
Bishop c4 I can play Bishop a6 and I'm
going to be able to even if you play e5
I'm going to be able to take and take on
hit six and I okay yeah gonna be a draw
we she this Knight is eliminated and now
Q I mean I think Knight c3 is a very
interesting move but now I'm very
curious to see what hobby has four
Knights a home right okay also for
Bishop b4 there was another plan which
is e takes d5 and makes db5 then I me
just want to sit on d6 but then the
question is to all your queen of four
ideas work here so for ya here 96 yeah
should be reasonable right 96 bach a
queen of four you're saying
yeah well queen of four here exactly
yeah that diagonal is looking very loose
and this doesn't need so I but I got 98
and for them I know the name Queenie
five so this might not be maybe I have
to play an item or something and the
thing is even if you get your 98 defense
there's 94 Knight of 6 check right yeah
lamb my caffeine on that square of some
point Ali Ali yeah I think the e5 line I
think the one you gave looked pretty
convincing if and maybe there's
something besides Knight d5 that Bobby
has but a line a line like that makes a
lot of sense basics yeah and this I
think would because I'm right yeah one
pawn short of a
winning angry okay it'll be interesting
to see if Fabi has has something else in
mind but I I I wanted to shout out again
because you made early reference when
you first joined us about this alpha0
show to rush the HP pawn and we've
talked about that as an idea that a lot
of players have added said to their
approach to some of these positions so
okay we'll see if Bobby can get
something something of an attack I the
other games are rolling on I find it
kind of interesting that after what
looks like a lot of preparation in a
well-known Berlin mvl and grish ik from
what I can see haven't moved for quite
some time this was interesting that he
is the real a stalled it makes its its
Sasha Gray shook with the black pieces
Danny it's okay I thought so but I have
to ask right we are dealing with
technology these are physical chess
boards relaying games to many many web
sites around the world so your vision
you you know these positions but what
are your I mean we know that Maxime is
is one of the you know the best prepared
positions on either side of a Berlin but
you mentioned that he played g4 right
away on h4 in the fact that Grichuk has
gone into a bit of a think is what are
your thoughts about where this is headed
in why why Sasha has kind of slowed down
here he likes to yeah it's quite healthy
what he does I mean it doesn't mean that
he has to end up with five minutes later
but I think it's very impressive how he
sits down spends 15 20 minutes at some
stage and really gets himself to focus
his game with the young for instance he
was much better as it turned out so if
he can I don't know how he should go
about it maybe wroking f8r okay we
should say it like he did in the other
game or just go 90 75 96 and then bring
it to c4
you're highlighting a play in two
Rema new for the night to take advantage
of the week queenside I don't already
see the attraction for white in this
position I simply I mean g4 is desirable
but I don't think so much that I would
want to destroy my pawn structure right
away so I would have considered it but
you know Maxine didn't make this up
right now so we will try to understand
try to go deeper in in fact this this
still looks like it's employed before
right but but I think the game from
Zagreb last year between Gary and
Nakamura was this exact line I can
actually just look it up I feel like
we've we've actually seen these games
between Maxime and Nakamura in our own
events online here I feel like the when
they when they've thrown down in some
Berlin blitz battles I mean this
position you you highlighted g4 seems at
least for you not not not your not your
taste
mainly because black goes out of his way
to play these h5 and then H for extended
lines in the Berlin precisely to make h4
undesirable because it will destroy the
structure yet Maxime goes right for it
and obviously you know you highlighted
an interesting plan black can relocate
try to take advantage of the newly
doubled an isolated Queen side Poland's
looks pretty solid to me Danny sorry to
interrupt but I did just confirm by
quick search and Peter Dockers of course
he's on everything he confirmed that
this was the game between Gary and
Nakamura from the Grantchester last year
and okay so King f8 was played here and
I'm guessing that maybe that's not the
best move I don't know it looks maybe 97
to d5 like you were saying looks good to
me
but King f8 was played and I came in the
advocacy group so is 97 met in some way
by something tricky right obviously
there's no there's no discoveries or
anything right away taking the bishop
would would not be in exchange that
favors white at all but but is there is
there something else that that white has
here I don't know I've always I'm always
whenever I have the bishop on f4 in
these borough
looking at a way to punch through e6 so
a move that keeps coming to my mind is
like c4 to like try to open things up
you know Bishop takes c4 I get e six
these types of tactics c4 Bishop c4 you
see I don't know if it's worth anything
I'm just throwing out ideas as far as
how white would try to meet 97 because
if you just close your eyes I mean black
is threatening h3 black is gonna play
Knight d5 if you highlighted vichy like
where's the beef for white what's the
concrete plan here yes well that
particularly for Bishop c4 e6 I mean I
could take on e6 first of all the second
one was coming in to f6 you go knight of
seven I go to takes h3 I want my clip c7
and you know I want checkmate again
sorry I'm on one trip maybe Bishop c7 to
threat and 86 yeah so c7 then I can take
c6 tactical alert you know that's a pawn
that you don't right away there wasn't
something like I mean okay I'm just
gonna now rook d7 doesn't work
I want something aggressive here it
doesn't look like there's anything
better than knight of seven like you
said yeah okay rook age three I mean to
my eyes if take c6 works like this
just pointing out then yeah
unfortunately this is an idea this whole
idea is kind of suspect okay 97
maybe c4 not really possible are we are
we just slow playing it in traditional
Berlin style you play G for it to stop
Bishop takes h3 mean 95 with a retreat
of the bishop and you're you know trying
to eventually
structurally this seems really awful for
wife right so you have compromised
queenside pawns and the CC pawns to a
pawn so white sort of needs to act
relatively quickly because the line way
we've seen 97 on the board sorry Robert
go ahead no I mean the long term really
doesn't seem to do well for one at all
but I'm sort of wondering if there is
some kind of you know idea you were just
talking about G for King up to King g3
h4 because while it looks ugly for wet
on the Queen side it's not easy to pile
a pressure and actually tackle those
pawns
yeah if we go for a slow playing like
this 95 Bishop d2 Knight b6 king of two
knights e4 King g3 just giving a crazy
liner I mean okay in which position
would be play after my c4 internal mic
c4 for instance
okay rook t8 cut also people I don't
define I could maybe go rodier uh-huh
okay I'm there now yeah rook ta yeah so
instead of 96 I could go to b8 yep yep
yeah anyway I don't do it bishop c 125
who knows
I can also blast out you know shut down
the D file for a while right
positionally again I mean we favor black
structure of all the for all the reasons
we talked about the Queen side is it's
completely crippled but but that's what
I wonder is if there's if there's not a
king of two king g3 h4 h5 and you know
these positions have probably been kh4
played very quickly by Maxime who's
apparently gonna flex his time advantage
here and and see if he can get grishnack
grishnack even even further down on the
clock you know you mentioned you like
that you like that he'd really takes the
time there but how many times have you
as one of Alexander's peers you've
played them so many times how many times
have you seen him not have enough time
when it matters most I mean you've been
known as a very fast player throughout
your career what are your thoughts on
the right balance there between taking a
lot of time but that was like he just
took about 50 minutes on one single move
to play 97 right I mean what are your
thoughts on how he manages the clock if
it's time he needed to settle in then
he's doing well but how do you
it was on this move 97 he spent all that
time minutes yeah I'm pretty sure
official novelty right Timothy played by
played in the game with Alexander we can
we can assume that he'll be able to cope
with less time than other people but I
mean I would with all my prescriptions
for coming down and thinking I think in
hours too much yeah he spent 15 minutes
on 97 yeah okay yeah that's that's just
quite hard 150 minutes is no problem in
this position I mean it's a ballad if
you've solved one or two immediate
problems you can play the rest of the
game and the rest of that you can get to
the time control easily with 45 minutes
so okay it's not that kind of position
where there's their queens and two
bishops
very complex structure well many more
hard decision the media one or two more
decisions but you get them right and
then it's easy to play visually can I
ask you just one kind of structural
question here is but my age for is white
intending to play rook to be one at some
moment because with the rook on b1
either you commit your pawn to a score
like b6 or b5 which takes away the nice
journey or you're tied down to the
defense of it so I don't H for just
seems like a move that it gives the g4
square and that should be an
advantageous thing for black to have but
that sort of leads you to think like
well what is Maxime doing is playing
very quickly what are someone's deeper
ideas and probably one is one of those
moves that is my idea what some
questions the first thing that popped
into my head when I say h4 was you're
threatening to move the knight - maybe
like efore and c5 in some positions
because with h3 no longer a problem the
night on g5 is suddenly a little more
free to roam so I like your Brooke b1
idea but I just wanted to add before
vichy gives his thoughts and tells us
both what we need to know but is there
also an idea there to free up the
Knights duties - maybe relocate to a
square like c5 yes baby will be the
point because what I want to do is on
plane
to me for but I don't want allow Ruchi
six and here j6 would work because of a
child hmm and if you go to your hedge
five let's say I think what's
coefficient G five or something and on
this side if X if ie six then I'm not a
fan of this idea but and I haven't
studied this variation for a while but
I'm gonna hold my thoughts and see how
it develops because clearly it is a
theoretical line that these guys will be
playing I must study this particular
variation in a while you think the fact
that Maxime played H for so quickly I
mean we already highlighted that when we
first joined the board with you
Maxime plays for G for despite it being
sort of structurally ill-advised the
whole reason black plays this line in
the Berlin in theory was to stop G for
cuz it'll create these broken structure
but Maxime says no I know what I'm doing
I'm gonna go for it and now he's very
quickly responded to critics fifty
minute think with age for I don't know I
guess I'm a little bit biased toward the
fact that I feel like I've seen Maxine
be more well prepared than even many
many of the other world's elite in these
positions that he still has some idea of
what he's doing here because he does I
mean he had warning as well
he saw preparing him simple right so
there's no way he could be under bandits
after a rest day so there's no way no he
has something concrete in mind and he's
evidently happy it's I'm not
enthusiastic about the position but that
doesn't mean anything means are watching
us so no I mean it's it's it'll be just
you see what happens I I want to draw
attention to another alpha 0h pawn
running up the board if that's okay is
one more yeah we've got we've got a nice
giri throwing throwing the h pawn to h4
and maybe it'll go all the way to age
three on the board versus Dingley red so
the last couple moves everybody after
the trade on b4 we saw h5 and then h4
from the Dutchmen and now 92 from
Dingley Ren so your thoughts on the
current live position here between
Dingley rena nigiri
[Music]
and I'm gonna find really again I'm a
wet blanket today but I mean here he
plays h3 Bishop f1 then it's got to be
the thing is when you see these
computers generate play after h h4 h 3
it's very hard to do for us right and
that's something to keep in mind it's
very hard to get right for us but you
know again I'm not trying to draw Misha
page 3 or something ok yeah yeah 1994
and then the pawn is hanging well also
the g5 and so on but ok ok if you're
gonna go to study these positions it
pays off because it is it is very useful
to have that common history but you see
as soon as you see h3 sorry cut you of
this sheet then what is immediately
trying to trade Queens right right as
soon as the poor man's blood makes that
decision which you can't take back
obviously there are mine ok I'm in the
mindset I'm trading Queens off and I'm
gonna win your H Farnum at the end of
the day so before we left to find out of
the way maybe yeah yeah Bishop f1 I can
play my d4 and then if you go night
before I can go Knight g5 so that might
be enough
ok so you don't think he plays h3 anyway
you think this is a new 40s and get a
trade I mean hey g3 also has some the
better chance of getting an attack of
the king size later are you highlighting
the fact that we can quit this before
and then yeah I never miss evading that
this is a custom upon right with night
before so then yeah not here but the
line with Queen g4 I didn't even there
might be form I'm just collecting
94 and then what black would play I
don't what are you I don't know I was
hoping you come up with a brilliant
mating attack should be seven and ninety
four right and slightly technical ah3
here but we'll see what I was thinking
is that if you know black doesn't have
to commit to either those decisions but
I know that once you play h3 now you've
given white a clear purpose right so
that's why I certainly would not make
that kind of commitment
the backing of preparation or I see
something concrete because it just feels
like you're giving white a very clear
path whereas what you're saying with
Bishop d7 the slower approach you still
have to worry about h3 at some moment
and of course h6 g3 is much more
acceptable if the Queen's are indeed
going to be traded off right yeah Bishop
d7 is looking more and more like the
most reasonable choice here I mean
sometimes after Bishop d7 black also can
play g6 King g7 and keep that and then
and then you'll be amazed how fast the
attack develops if you can get into a
shape but you have to make several
preparatory required preparatory moves
in advance and then at some point you
might get lucky
yeah okay
well I mean good you're about to say
some horrible catch off no no just my
feeling is I think blacks not ready for
you hey h3 here so you should probably
go we should be self
the again I'm trying to draw back
attention to this alpha zero thing the
influence it has over the top players in
the world of course Leela being the you
know the the engine people use most
often now I mean obviously we know these
guys are using neural nets in their
preparation right I mean I'm sure your
you do the same right how much do you
think that that has influenced you know
because you again you mentioned not
trying to draw attention to that dinner
but you you blew my mind when you were
talking about the fact that it kind of
showed the computers we're talking about
ways to play positions that maybe you
wouldn't consider before you have no
plan and so might as well rush the H
pawn it gives you long-term chances
seeing what we have in the game with
Viviano now of course here within each
giri do you think that that is a little
bit of the neural net preparation that
influences some of the some of the
approaches here
yes I think in this case once you've
seen the idea for once you've seen the
idea then it's a little bit like a virus
it stays there and maybe not the best
example right now but you know it kind
of stays in your head and every once in
a while you just think H by it and
you're slightly more open to the idea of
tossing that point on the board before
you would restrain yourself small and
now yeah definitely there are stylistic
huge stylistic changes in the way people
play I think once you realize the remove
is possible then you think well I can do
it all right
and flows upwards from there right okay
well I'm I'm uh
I like the idea you added there
especially with g6 and King g7 of course
everything's a little risky White has
the long-term positional edges in this
structure anyway when you've got these
hanging pawns in the backwards C pawn so
what kind of black is looking to do
something dynamic to compensate because
if it weren't for this H pawn idea you
just give white moves I mean you're
thinking Knight d4 Queen c5 let me
double Brooks on the C file I'm just
gonna anchor in on what's a horrible
positional weakness on c6 so so kind of
black has to do something dynamic here
rather than just sit on a worse
positional pawn structure right yeah I
think the reason they went to eat do it
not to a force because this started yeah
so because if not otherwise it is on h7
but once it came to h5 nothing wisely
closer yeah we need some pieces over
here on the Kings side to watch our
ports up I'm excited to see where this
one comes to I know one like
yeah what 65 plate already
h5 was played with the night still
unknown I could make fun a ghostly ajg
will be the other option
but there at least we got black to
commit one way or the other
you think maybe you should have gone
with the 92-93 idea you feel like this
nice even if I put the knight on f3 then
maybe h3 and 94 works but it still feels
a bit loose to me which ff1 make me fall
because now I don't have 95 but right
and here it's high there is some
long-term compensation maybe
if I take on c6 maybe little quiz except
six but then you still just have night
instead of take on c6 I'm kind of 9594
situation anyway yes lady 594 I do
believe we should be same exact thing
but oh but then h3 as well yeah I'm
skeptical
we have a lot to learn still about how
to get this right because alpha zero
just pushes an H pawn and puts a queen
on h1 and everyone thinks oh I can do
that too now right and that it's not so
simple
but I agree with you I mean of course I
do but 92 to f3 to me looks if you're
Knights an e2 it's really not trying to
go to f4 so an f3 at least says two
options going to d4 or Evod and it
forces blacks hand to commit h6 g3 so
you've clarified the kingside a little
more and then f3 is a more active square
than on e 2 so I'm totally with you I
think that that perhaps was a something
that Tingler would like to take back but
do you think there's possibly who's
worth a five to a four for black at some
moment which is why I started on this
exactly I mean the thing is again blacks
playing on two fronts it because 92 then
could already play so I guess and you
might have to pause so Bishop d7 at some
point but can be yes so Brittany so it's
hard I mean it was hard to make this
choice you go to the side he might play
for you go c3 yeah and I also still
think I mean in that line you gave with
90 to h4 Knight f3 h3 Bhishma phone
because the knight no longer has your
idea Robert of going from E to to f4
which of course makes h3 a dead duck
over there I mean there is something to
be said for okay IH 3 bishop f1 you
could maybe play Bishop d7 now you don't
have to go all in for an attack with 94
I don't know I mean maybe maybe he
didn't like then I don't have three in a
position like this where 90 to h4 night
of three h3 Bishop f1 Bishop d7 it's not
so simple how white you know takes
advantage of this h3 pawn being so far
up the board I kind of like Blackmore
here no no let's
95 was still the idea that I wanted to
yeah okay yeah there's still h3 point
being of a problem there
so maybe that's why you'd like 94
instead of Bishop d7 so take your pick
right okay all right
well 92 was committed from Dingley Renan
and maybe maybe he'll regret not having
the night on the a3 squared we'll see if
a niche can come up with some kind of
attack note that a niche is up but I
don't think at this early stage with the
night on b1 you can calculate that
precisely and that far so I think
sometimes of the night c3 or d2 is just
a few right okay just yeah comfort thing
but but he is he is trying to calculate
you see Dingley rent is down more than
40 minutes on the clock I was gonna say
Anisha I'm on the clock here not sure I
don't think that's totally indicative of
them still being in prep we're more just
anisha's somehow a little more
comfortable in this position at this
point
all right well but but usually at some
point all these you can if you push all
your root bones then you open and we'll
think and at some point the fund runs
out responds are at that point so let's
say that happens yeah it makes this
moment critical whether you're just
gonna take g3 so that you don't have to
regret playing h3 later right I sort of
like white here me too I think a big
shame yeah I was gonna say a big shame
for black because you can't share the d7
square with your knight in your bishop
right because whites plan of 94 Queen c5
seems pretty straightforward in many
regards and you need a 27 and
protects c6 but you also want to play 97
when Queen c5 happens so you can kick
the Queen out or trade on before so you
can take with the a pawn but I was
saying pieces can't share squares sad
part of chess interesting decision that
it's doing back to Fabiano I love it
yeah he's taken on c4 and gone Queen d2
and and you can see that white would
normally lose a piece in this kind of
position except that with the spawner at
six you know different dynamic with the
Queen always trying to land on right
well again I mean I feel like you called
it you made it as a joke but I keep
coming back to it because I think the
pawn on h6 is a thorn in black side
especially with the Queen's on the board
well it's really a card isn't it I mean
you can play any position and you
calculate variations normally except
suddenly there's a magic Queen g7 out of
the air right there that's the kind of
feel I mean after that they continue
with the narrow positional motives on
the other flank but white has this extra
hanging in the air always and the factor
so I'm too greedy to what could you do a
bishop before I don't like you met you
know I can probably take this before
even we should be foreseen
no buts gonna say maybe just take these
six instead of Bishop d4 I mean yeah so
you take on e6 I but I take with the
Queen and then you go Queen da check we
should have fate and that that must be
awful if we can't be tonight I
can go 95 yeah I know 95 you can take 26
I go Queen e8
it doesn't seem to be fun but it's it's
certainly a very very tough position to
be black now I mean ya know I think we
should be four we don't want what about
he takes deep okay
he takes d5 so Knight takes d5 Knight
takes Knight different taking II for
Bishop takes no I I'm just showing
everybody go ahead yeah Bishop b5 II d5
but then again how do we follow up
because if I go Bishop d6 you have Queen
B - and then I second that Evo g7 square
yeah so it's harder for me to maybe
instead of he takes d5 I should play
something like Bishop d6 is that Cosimo
you said Bishop d6 right away yeah well
that's a that's a brave rookie move yeah
but I want to get an e file and then
if I can maybe have enough six in it is
the main point you don't want to play e5
right away because white might just push
d6 and yeah well yeah then we have
basics I don't think I can stop it
so I don't go yeah no I don't see how
just trying to translate for the face
I'm not asking for me I'm asking for a
friend
make sure no I'm kidding actually no but
Vichy if we five when it's instead of
Bishop d6 right so b5 b6
g6 anyone exactly okay so you go Bishop
c6 but now let me play Bishop
I mean you still have 95 ideas
I'm saying in the in the current
position if black fuzzy five right
Bishop c6 I'm saying 95 I think this
point is you completion takes d5 right
exactly
I thought I might have some crazy
Intermezzo like d7 but you actually have
Queenie should do five you have f6 that
doesn't work so I would play eight dates
D phone
and then you just go Queens
yeah but also Danny was right Queen
instead of Bishop e7 to begin with Queen
64 yeah I think Queen Dixie for was a
key at Intermezzo because it threatens
made on g2 instead of Bishop e7 o3 you
have check yeah check them before I
assume checkouts it actually one check
Queen h4 ah that's the key no exactly
oh wow goes the dynamite white gets
checkmate you have to I still on Bishop
c5 Wow and then I came back most naked
wrong
uh-huh after waiting five a door but
nothing wrong yeah yeah I think so
okay okay I'm back to the initial
position just to show that we got
something happening here everybody is
you got to deal with the deep on and not
lose lose to checkmates on g7 in the
process if you're in upon the Aussie so
we're looking at V she's maybe looking
at two moves 'if I've from Robert
allowing d6 or vicious Bishop d6 to stop
that idea yan is on the clock trying to
come up with this let's go back to
vicious Bishop d6 first and see if we
can make that work
no but after he found actually d6 Bishop
c6 I have d7
okay so ii 5d6 Bishop d6 d7 and if
Bishop d7 then I want to UM 95 no I'm
not we should be six to the other one
yeah I'm sorry I'm too many modes yeah
yeah 95 years and once I get a negative
six
em
that's the unpleasant if you go Quincy
sits at Bishop g5 and so I get my mic on
f6
[Music]
on top of that you're gonna have to step
away their Bishop which means I probably
get to the eighth rank as well right so
Bishop e6 if I just let you go 96 check
I think King 6 check instead of 6 check
and then Queen eh-eh
in a queen Sierra always have right just
to survive
yeah maybe you do because I mean it
looks agree that I could attack it looks
terrible though I'm with you because I
mean black can hardly move but if I get
my Bishop to e7 and my queen to ca
things like that I feel like maybe black
can wriggle his way out of it but it
looks suspicious okay should be six
maybe five let's have a look at he five
them because if black can play Bishop d6
and then bring
I mean it's a global situation in theory
it's in blacks interest to maintain this
tension between d5 meaning okay we're
looking at E 5 and the idea of pushing
but you're also giving white to
protected passed pawn it if there isn't
something concrete maybe white has other
ideas here although there is Bishop b4
coming if you're if you don't do
anything after e5 yeah ah ha ha very
nice yeah
but yeah I mean something that worries
me about Bishop d6 tones starting
because it for bugs can't white play e5
like the Queen and on the D files are so
strong Froy yeah you take and obviously
physics then I go Queen
defending I mean I have my chickens head
like this is this is you could play but
I don't know that I'm gonna do it I mean
there's 27 there's 95 there's all kinds
of moves these six Queens is 795
Queenie's
which move you're thinking of after
Queen c7
I got a like maybe five
yeah maybe five looks interesting Queen
d7 looks interesting
I don't even yeah Queen decent idea can
I go we should have six and can you stop
the Gypsy sings
yeah I'm actually I thought I was gonna
get my bishop
yeah but just maybe we should stick to
he find them I think we should be 65 is
quite well he took he took on d5 in the
game by the way oh wow oh wow yeah we
looked at this and we really like 95 and
thought that this was uh okay so 95 we
should be fine 85 maybe I'm called Queen
before that way I take away all the dark
squares that you want to use maybe this
well it's actually beautiful geometry
you take away d4 it took away b2 c3 any
of those yeah and if you go Queen c1 now
I can go Queen B for let's say Oh Queen
yeah yeah and now if Quincy's six then I
have
I mean this is still one of the
positions you highlight it is very
tricky for black because in the end of a
lot of variations they're still mating
ideas black has to watch out for yes I
mean maybe it wouldn't go as far to say
it's a to result position for sure but
it definitely feels like one that white
is in control here
yes but actually I think I'm what I'm
claiming is that black is equal here
okay and you think in this let me take
on a - okay you're gonna go let me just
go for the line you were talking about
yeah maybe we should be focusing but
let's have a look you're saying Bishop D
for threading Queen f6
so it if Queen before knocking before
Quincy one knock we need for Quincy six
I just my playing around that line yeah
I was going for that line and then I
went with Queen b12 take a - yeah
and what do you do if you go Queen f6 I
have Queen takes d5 and I'm in time with
Queen d6 check yeah my idea was Bishop
d4 first we should be four then I can go
Queen Dido take said six check but
that's not that's not going to be nice
or I can go Queen a3 with idea Queen d6
check I would not do this at the ball
simply because it's very easy to make a
blunder but ya know you might be right
though grabbing the a pawn right if the
computers are gonna drive the pawn to h6
and you got to play like a computer and
go pawn grabbing on a - I was about to
say taking on a 2 did not come to my
mind at all but as a way to survive
sometimes you just gotta steal all your
opponent's pawns and bail out with
there's possible honestly honestly
[Laughter]
but Vigi you clearly getting accustomed
being a commentator because what I
always say is the ideas that I come up
with commentating often our ideas I
would never be able to find over the
board because I just sacrifice people's
pieces and allow them to get passed
pawns there now sometimes it works out
it's a lot easier and go pawn you sound
just like me I'm very happy right now
yeah you're making my day ok any any
outside I'm gonna try to keep winning
this position as white because I know
nothing but unsound checkmate attacks so
let me what if I take on d5 with the
pawn instead of the night thank you for
me here cuz bishop before I have Bishop
d4 I still want the Delaware predicts d5
Oh Queen takes d5 yeah wait a second
well wait a most of all Bishop takes c3
and Queen takes d5 is a draws I don't
see what you're aiming for a vision to
negative six King h8 okay I'm I'm
claiming that's a draw as well but I
would rather make it easy
all right well o95 is played vichy
steals my my fun with an unsound mating
attack and I'm gonna I'm gonna steal a
few seconds for our team here Vichy and
take a very quick break I hope you can
stay with us we're gonna we're gonna
reset a couple things don't go anywhere
fans when we come back more round four
from the 2020 feat a candidates
tournament and just a couple minutes
[Music]
in
[Applause]
[Music]
and we are back once again with chest
out comes coverage of the 2020 feat a
candidates tournament
Robert eight players came in and I don't
think a single one of those eight guys
has disappointed us with the fighting
spirit they brought to the table here in
Russia I'm thrilled that we have these
eight players contending for the
championship and sorry now for the
champion for the right to earn a spot in
the world champion to face Magnus
Carlsen and these eight players are
hungry they are working their hardest
both in the months preceding the event
or if you're Mexico Sheila Groff in the
seven days or so preceding the event but
look at the name of top the leaderboard
there Maxime Bashar Lou Grove in a tie
for first place that's two out of three
and right now we were just talking and
during the break Danny his position is
fascinating he's playing really quickly
and he clearly is hungry for more
victories yeah and we talked about the
fact that the the preparation that he's
bringing here is is obvious just because
okay you look at the time of the clock
we know that it's grishnak playing black
and it's become a bit of a part of the
storyline people always wondering when
will Russia go into his next think tank
well we had our answer he took 50
minutes before playing the move 97 that
if you're just joining us was the
improvement over the game between the
Hikaru Nakamura and a nice giri from the
grand chester in zagreb last year or
maybe not improvement it was the novelty
King of fate was played in that game but
after 97 MBL doesn't miss a beat
instantly plays h4 he sacrificed the c3
pawn now and this whole idea that
started with a structural kind of gambit
back on move 15 where MBL meets Bishop
b4 Robert not with trying to stop Bishop
takes c3 but allowing the doubled and
horrible structure on both sides of the
board now is is it's clearly something
he has in mind right vision on who was
just joining us and by the way we'll be
with back with us here in just a few
minutes so don't go anywhere the champ
will return very soon and give us his
thoughts but I said you off-camera and
I'll just say here for everyone because
you know if I'm wrong it's always more
fun for me to be humiliated in front of
thousands people but I think I think
MBL's gonna if not win this game brings
serious pressure and showed that this
was a start-to-finish berlin prep this
idea looks very dangerous the more we
look at it the night moving from efore
and some of the danger that can come
with Bishop g5 and the rooks on the
defiled Robert my brain is just getting
amped up here for an unsound checkmate
attack well I want to point out that
night 84 was the response chosen by Gro
shocked and he had options and he could
have gone Knight to d5 or I don't think
made to be if I were so just Knight to
d5
but the minute 8:4 stops that really
pester some idea you mentioned earlier
with 94 to c5 because the 984 not only
threatens to come back to c5 itself but
stops White's Knight from landing on
that square which would be a huge
nuisance so that's the first thing you
had mentioned so kind of rook swinging
to the F file and trying to go after the
f7 pawn during the break which is a
great idea but unfortunately for white
there's no easy way to execute it
because yeah you would love to play rook
f1 first said your rook on d3 so active
rook at forums mimic Bishop c4 and
that's a problem for white and rook f3
allows rook to d8 in the rook will come
to d7 defending the f7 square so it
seems like while black is down an hour
and a half on the clock and white is
down upon on the board it feels like
we're just you know there you're
jockeying for position here yeah an
extra pawn for black a better pawn
structure but white is more active with
his pieces and that's the compensation
that he claims yeah and you know the
question is will there be some practical
factors here that weigh in right because
obviously with with only 16 minutes left
to make the next roughly 20 moves right
19 moves exactly to reach move 40 and
and the pressure only just mounting
griffix gonna have some tough things to
solve without a lot of time to do so I
mean okay I was joking about the idea of
it being an unsound checkmate attack but
there is still ideas of removing the
knight and putting the bishop on g5 to
hit d8 the sacrifice of coming to a4
which does guard c5 as you said Robert
is that you don't block the D file but
maybe Grisha can just do that with the
bishop right something like let me you
know 94 the rook moves
I mean maybe to g6 but I wasn't even
just gonna move it back
but if it goes to g6 I just want to show
like Bishop g5 can be met by Bishop d5
and black is actually looking to be in
just fine shape here all the fun to note
rookie to d1 is possible and that you
can't take Eve or cuz I made and I am
threatening c4 I don't know night-night
b2 stops all that at once with live in
York there you go okay
alright so Maxime Nell by the way taking
his first thing to the game I know we're
on move 21 but if you're just joining us
he has more time that he started with it
is a hundred minutes on the clock with
an increment so with an hour and forty
six means he's gained time with every
move and he's actually only now taking
his first real think of the game and
considering how quickly isn't playing
you alluded to this earlier that match
in the speed chess championship between
Hikaru Nakamura and Maxie rush Sheila
Grove was kind of like this or we saw
crazy Berlin theory 2025 moves deep
every single game and then finally one
of the players would sit for well in
that case was like three minutes it was
time to think but that's feels like what
we're seeing here and with an hour and
42 minutes on his clock Maxine has
plenty of time to wait through the
complications and try to come up with a
plan that said if Maxie doesn't find
something concrete he has sacrifice upon
his structure still isn't particularly
great and so you don't want not want to
allow I was in agree shucks to play him
with a rook d8 at the right moment
trade-off pieces and enter a superior
endgame and I would say the fact that
he's slowing down yes he has time to
figure it out but I would say that's the
first you know like I made my statement
of it with a chance to look like an
idiot in front of thousands that Maxine
wood would get some real pressure maybe
win in a well-prepared Berlin now that
he's slowing down that makes me nervous
because for the first time maybe he's
not exactly sure how he justifies upon
sacrifice and the positionally
devastated queenside couldn't that also
mean that we shook maybe not as subpar
move but maybe not the main computer
recommended recommendation it's a good
it's a good point you bring up because
it is something I think people forget
that often when a grandmaster first goes
into thinking about his opponents move
it's not because their opponents move is
always good right sometimes it's the
first sign that hey you didn't play my
prep and
maybe I don't remember the answer now
but that's probably because you're not
playing the engine best recommendation
so it's a it's an interesting point the
other games rolling along quickly flash
them if possible well let's show Dingley
ren and anna nice giri who by the way
the trade has happened on g3 so in each
decided no alpha zero for him just
simply makes an exchange and plays
Bishop d7 and now your point that Vichy
agreed with of the night not being on d4
it's kind of coming into play I feel
like maybe Gary's position is a little
more comfortable here as black and then
it would have been if White had like
just the kind of straightforward bind on
the on the Queen side and the c5 square
well the c5 square might be occupied
with the knight in the near future if I
go 93 to stop it boy yeah but when you
play Knight d3 that opens the
fourth-ranked from the black queen so
after 93 queen g4 feels like the kind of
active move you need and I know
checkmates always on your brain queen
age 594 quit you didn't even need me to
say it you already drawing the arrows
I'm several highlights ahead of you
buddy ya know it's but I mean it's not a
bad idea I think in this particular
position 95 is actually possible sure
than Queen is 5
h5 and I guess if I take d7 you're
saying fine exchange or black given that
the knight is probably actually a pretty
a pretty good minor piece in this
structure white no longer has the bind
on these positional squares because of
it
hmm okay interesting rook FCA played and
he should by the way no longer up on the
clock if you're just joining us not more
than three moves ago and each had about
a forty minute time advantage so over
the last few moves starting starting
with night II to that that advantage on
the clock has dwindled away and we're
now roughly equal with both sides under
an hour to play
yeah I still like whites position for
sure because the c-pawn the backward
policy six always something you need to
keep your eye on it if you have to be
attentive to that pond you're not going
to be able to ask you the plans that you
want to do so queen c5 always an option
night d3 to get the night to c5 of
course is an idea and may even work to
d1 to d2 bring the other work to c1
white has flexibility that black does
not in a position like this yeah it's a
good point you highlighted a4 as one of
the you know ideas to keep in mind if
you're black and on the worse side of
the structure the main point everybody
is that if you just gave white a bunch
of moves we've been highlighting this
since we had Vichy on the Queen will
come to c5 eventually you will you know
hopefully doubled rooks on the C file
and then gang up you know whether the
knight comes from d3 to e5 or e2 to d4
White has full control over the board
playing for two results so one way black
kind of disrupts that doesn't move like
a four to make me three a weakness if
you let me take or if you take you
actually give me a pass C pawn and maybe
we can a fought a four so the structure
isn't totally just dead for black yet
but if you give white some moves it only
gets worse for Geary from here this is a
might I mean I know that's not exactly
the same game but the the the storyline
of this game robbers reminded me of one
of the last times you and I commented on
a pairing between these two which was at
the sync field Cup where Dingley rent
won one of his nicest games of the event
right as white against a nice giri in a
game that started out unclear but then
he slowly worked that small advantage
that he is kind of known to do so I'm I
don't know just have been having
memories having flashbacks to Geary
Geary kind of you know Randy h-bomb but
if he doesn't get anything look for the
positional grind to be on we know
Dingley ren just super technical super
precise really at home in those kind of
positions and Dingley rend after Noah to
start you don't hear people saying
anymore oh he's out of it and what's
wrong with him
now people looking at his game against
five in a car wanna an excellent video
recap you did but they're analyzing it a
little more indefinitely Wow he handled
that preparation really well and it
played a pretty superb game and now I'm
looking at his position in a second
white in a row I'm sitting there
thinking this is exactly
type of position that if you ask tingly
Ren what does he want against a nice
giri here's the epitome of that it's
it's picturesque in how nice it is to
play for white and how difficult it
would be for black to find a concrete
plan instead of a reactionary set of
decisions well you mentioned that the
video I did with ding li Ren getting
that victory over Fabiano Caruana
there's our our game within the game
kind of round three report card for
those of you that missed it obviously it
was an interesting game with lots of
lots of exciting prep honestly by
Fabiano for a lot for a lot of the first
half but then eventually it caught up
with him and making that blunder h6 and
the game arc showed that white was
really in control from there on out so
as you said with that victory there
almost a perfect game from ding a 98%
accuracy score and then we look at the
live game here this is gonna be the kind
of position that he's right at home in
as you said so alright we'll see what he
comes up with here I'm predicting Quincy
5 before 93 because I actually don't
like allowing Queen g4 but but we'll see
what they do by the way MBL has played
rook f3 so the F file idea is is what
the doctor ordered rook f3 by the way
again
rook f1 would have allowed Bishop c4 but
something Robert and I mentioned coming
back from the break if white goes for
the F pawn here kind of tricky for black
to stop this plan how do you deal with
this move rook at 3
yeah it's not easy to meet because 19:7
is actually a threat that's not I wasn't
renewed but probably for the first time
it's a legitimate idea yeah because
let's say you make a sex just yeah just
show tonight f7 Bishop f7 Bishop takes
h6g takes h6 and that keep on I mean
it's going musics maybe even work f6
would have been better though because h6
hangs just work everyone look you're
just winning all that fate what a move
so that's a skewer and we obviously
don't have to be so accommodating we
don't have to play a six but I think
this idea still stands if you play rook
to d8 that was my initial instinct of
rook da Vinci seven but now Knight takes
f7 you have to take back on f7 because
you're under attack in a million
different ways and now we think do we do
it play e6 we play rook to f1 again you
know the rooks do well against the minor
pieces when you have clear passed pawns
and White has this a pawn as well as
this G or H pawn that's going to be a
passer and it's extremely dangerous for
Alexander Christian especially
considering the time situation yeah no I
do that it's a the Brooks can outplay
the minor pieces when the board is also
split meaning there's weaknesses on both
sides so if you have you know the e pawn
and then you have these other pawns here
and the rooks can you can do kind of
like what a queen would do against
multiple pieces sort of flex that she's
the more powerful piece and shift
quickly this is this is a position just
look at it the minors are uncoordinated
you know you need them on whatever you
need them on d5 and e6 together
blockading and outmaneuvering the rooks
which is probably not going to happen in
a position like this so yeah because the
e6 for white there's just devastating
you're right no no it again yeah takes
takes east six let's say the bishop goes
to G I mean I want activity but I'm
nervous about rook up six coming in a
seven actually a seven is just gonna
crush ouch owie town actually okay so
even just on a concrete level the knight
takes f7 might be winning if you make a
misstep here that's
it's difficult I mean again the clocks
are ticking right we are getting live
relay of course from from Russia and and
so they'll be updated when grishnack
moves but this is okay there he goes
right there we jump from sixteen to
eleven five minutes is less than Grichuk
has spent on many of the moves before
this but it's still a lot of time to
take when you only have 16 minutes this
is not a fun position to play because
white plans are now becoming readily
apparent the rook is under attack in f3
so start with some Maybrook f4 hitting
the gonna mate for swimming next rook
over to f1e 6 is an opportunity for
white this is very very dangerous
and I'm starting to agree with you
didn't I hate to say it but using MDL
showing some prep and going to score no
real good win here it's looking more and
more likely as the moves go on well
thanks to thanks to you to giving me
some confidence back because when I
first saw 94 I thought oh MB I was
thinking but actually like you said I
mean often when that move is played
someone's been blitzing out their
preparation and they and they pause upon
their opponent's unexpected move that's
actually a bad sign right but for the
opponent because it means alright now
you played a move the engine didn't like
and I'm gonna make sure I take my time
to make sure I punish it so that I can
convert on on all my preparations so
alright MBL one of the last men to join
the field will be he be the guy that
wins it all it all Tony plays magnus
carlsen for the world championship this
is good this win would be a if he wins
this game to be a huge step in the right
direction Fabiano's game by the way no
surprise Vichy completely predicted the
line we were about to see
[Music]
Knight takes d5 was played the trade
happened and after Queen to before what
a nice geometrical defensive idea
offering offering the swap and holding
against the pawn rushing up Bobby has
just moved by the way it's been his move
for quite a while but he finally just
played the move Queen d3 wants to keep
the Queens on the board yeah trading off
the Queens in this particular position
could be problematic for why the pawns
she was highlighting that it's gone too
far it's overextended you know black
people f6 g5 and just win that pawn on
h6 so that's why Bobby plays queen d3
keeping those Queens on and they're
still checkmating ideas with that long
diagonal the dark squares being
vulnerable on blacks Kings side but the
idea is that vichy was saying for
blockading the pawn seem to still be
relevant here I just don't know what
black really does get any sort of
activity it's hard cuz it is even though
equal and I and I think you know best
play maybe maybe never should be just
fine but the long-term factors here are
very cute result is for white you know
it's you you were gonna be blockading
this and worrying about mating ideas
whether on the back rank or on g7 the
chances of really mobilizing blacks
combat advantage in the grünfeld pawn
structure the two-on-one it's just so
far-fetched at this point that it's
really you know whites in control will
he have enough is another question but
you know I will say that this she didn't
give him something of credit but I kept
trying to get him to talk about but he
in our and we had some we had some time
we caught up in st. Louis last year
Robert he mentioned specifically that
everyone's preparing with neural nets
and he said one of the common things
people are doing is just rushing these H
pawns because even if it doesn't work
out there's all these long-term mating
that ideas and I kept wanting him to
talk about it because he said and if
you're like everything about this game
is exactly the kind of thing he was
talking about it turns equal positions
into you know very difficult practical
holds for the for the black player or
for white whenever there's constant
mating Nets opportunities to blunder
right so I don't know I mean I think
this is gonna be a tricky thing that now
that the Queen's are still on the board
for neppo to hold in and you know you
know
or five-minute car wanna if we see these
through might everybody the standings
just neppo entered this in first place
and a tie with two out of three and five
in a car one who lost to Dingley wren he
is in the middle of the pack with one
and a half points so a holding with the
black pieces for nepo would be a huge
achievement and for fog on a car wanna
you're writing the ship not losing this
game but you really want to win you
don't want to stay behind those leaders
too long granted so it's a very long
tournament but I don't know if I'm Fabi
I'm getting that nervous each of when am
I gonna start scoring these victories to
get back on top of the leaderboard I
feel like he's he's probably still
feeling pretty confident cuz the
storyline for all of us after round
three was kind of dig me Ren is no
longer you know putting up a no fir
right he's on the board but you know I
spent a lot of time looking at that line
I didn't even get to say all the
variations I've spent probably way too
much time looking at the e5 novelty idea
he had and you know if Fabi makes a
couple different steps in that game
Robert we might be talking about an
absolutely brilliantly prepared victory
with with it with the second color I
mean I think that position is very
dangerous for white
you know the analysis at my blog shows
you can check it out that not just the
h6 blunder but right before that you
know ideas of that rookie five little
tempo it was not easy for day and
Dingley rent said the same thing after
the game right he said he felt like
black was really playing with a lot of
compensation for most the game so I
don't know I think hard wanna has shown
to be in pretty good form despite losing
that last round no but doesn't this show
good preparation but bad form isn't it
kind of exactly what I'm saying okay to
Schaben okay hey Robert I see you baby
he's game against Alex Aiko and that was
great preparation he executed perfectly
and extremely nice victory not taking
anything away from him but he had the
preparation he wanted he had Dingley
read in all sorts of time trouble trying
to figure out what to do in a very
complex rich position and then he
labeled it then put h6 in the world like
we what you had an initiative going
right and then you took your time to
play h6 and then Dingley Ryan was able
to regroup maybe feeling in bad form is
why he played that game on way past the
point where a lot of people thought he
should we had
Master Wesley so commenting in the chat
that it was it was long past overdue to
resign but you know obviously the Devi
question today gives fans a chance to
weigh in if you missed round three it
was it was surprising how long Fabiano
Caruana too many played on that game but
perhaps if we look at the final position
as you said when someone's feeling a bad
form we talked about this sometimes you
play on bad positions to just work out
the kinks in your calculation just to
get you know get the nerves out of the
way also emotionally there's a lot of
psychological theories that you
shouldn't resign right when you're
feeling at your worst emotionally play
it out give yourself a chance to relax
and let go right as far as the hangover
effect that can happen from a loss so
anyway
maybe that's why he played this game on
as far as he did but right now he's uh
he's engaged in this battle with you on
the pom Yoshi I'm checking on these
other games Robert can we just say that
this Wang Hao Alex ankle game is just
going so slow like nothing's happened
here over the last hour and a half we do
see a queen trade so finally finally
exchange of pieces this is the type of
game where you're playing for your small
plusses and wang hao he has control of
the c-file he's going to recapture on b3
but the night because the rook and a6 is
under attack so instead of offering a
trade and a way out of that attack you
play Knight takes b3 you already have
your work on the open file would love to
land on c7 and a slight little plus for
white because much of the action is not
to take place on the Queen side on you
and that Bishop on g7 is not helping out
in any sort of defense there where's the
bish 1b to help swipe like pawn a2 to a3
safeguard the a file and then start
occupying along the C file so I was
given a slight and also also the
measurement b2 if you try to play brook
c6 is black maybe denying a move rook c7
the bishop on b2 might quickly come to a
three and he sevens a problem right I
think you make a great point that if
we're comparing the bishop counterparts
that's all I'm saying the white bishop
is potentially much more effective here
than the black bishop on g7
yeah and I also see more plans for what
Bishop to b5 so you can try to play for
yourself is another idea and when one of
these nights coming to C or E 5 and when
the rook is going to land
see seven it's kind of a tricky
situation here for acrylics anko he is a
little bit down on the clock every
single move going forward will have a
subtlety and nuance that requires some
serious calculation you can't just play
intuitively here you know the feel is
important but you need to think
concretely because you're making one
little slip-up
then the advantage becomes overwhelming
and then it's going from a defensible
position to one that is just horribly
daunting task to hold what let's keep
looking at because I think you're you're
making a great point that you know I
joked when we first joined it that this
game took a long time to get anything
going and then I saw someone in chat
joke when we came to the board wait a
second blacks up a queen that was pretty
funny but okay if Knight takes b3 has
played everything you just said is is
really true black is is on thin ice here
despite it being a completely equal
looking structure those positions could
be some of the most risky you start
seeing one side is the first one with
access to the open files which is the
seventh rank and the pressure and here
comes a four and Bishop a three actually
after this Bishop b5 move I really like
your Bishop b5 idea have I told you that
yep you you know you have to like that
shirt on you and I really like the
Bishop b5 I did two things I haven't
told you I appreciated that Danny and I
mean where does the black rook go after
nine things b3 because if you stand the
a file you give me the C file if you
were to c6 then Bishop e5 comes with
that tempo even if you even if you stay
on the a father you might even play
Bishop b5 any I think your idea is
really strong because a4 and Bishop a3
is really irritating to deal with but
okay what do you think on rook e8 you
think you'd go rook c7 right away just
why not not you a four star with a four
okay flexible because that punk could
even go to a5 where it's well defended
and the b7 pawn is the target in the
position and I'll play Bishop b5 or play
a5 play Bishop a3 as you're suggesting
and it feels like white is just the one
pressing forward move after move and
don't forget this Bishop on a5 well it
looks very strong there are some
situations where you have to worry about
it getting trapped because if you ever
played a 76 right when you pause it
six and g6 inhibition one at five then
that's where it becomes iffy territory
controlled out of squares there it's one
of the reasons you tell beginner players
as a coach be very careful about
developments like that whenever you have
a fiend cut out structure just because
of strange tactics that can occur long
out taking his time here still on the
clock we can see it ticking away here of
course we're both expecting ninety xb3
but what is it about this guy's style
that he sneaks up on people and I know
that's maybe that's just you know a
silly thing to say he's playing in the
candidates tournament he won the chest
comvita a grand swiss i think he's you
know clearly a monster among men most
and most events he competes in but I
guess what I'm saying is a lot of people
wouldn't have picked him as a potential
early frontrunner but it's something
about his ability to turn and seem like
a tame position and I feel like he's now
gonna be playing a to result end game
for the rest of the game against Alex
Enco he just I feel like he gets in the
positions like that a lot and suddenly
you're like yeah walk out just one with
black against England around one who saw
that coming right well you raised a very
good question I think part of the answer
is he's overshadowed by his compatriot
yeah because Wang Hao is several years
older than being the Wren and was also
one of these superstars from China still
is but he became the highest rated
player in China alongside long you a
these two were really just they're
stable at the top of the game and then
he sort of fell off and people forgot
about him is rating out dipped he wasn't
getting the invites I think that Wren
was scoring all the invites then you
yangjia's well when you aim you reach
twenty seven seventy so Wong house sort
disappeared I don't really know what he
was up to but I've always had tremendous
respect for him as a player then you see
him go playing tournaments like in the
feed a grand Swiss an isle of man you're
like wait a sec yeah this guy is a
monster it isn't you know even lost a
step in fielding I think he's the
strongest he's ever been and that's a
scary proposition for all these other
players because you take someone like
this for granted and he starts squeezing
pressing these positions and it's only a
matter of time before you collapse and a
nice Giri is lucky that he survived that
because I think if you give that
position to Wang Hao say ten more times
he scores
eight victories from those
where's Robert talking about the the
previous the one of the previous run
games that Wang Hao had but okay he's
taking his time here we're still
expecting him to take with the night but
we're already really liking his chances
against Alex Enco a couple of the other
games have seen a little bit of progress
let's quickly flash
Maxine Bao hey the Groves game here
we've seen a couple moves the doubling
on the F file has occurred but grishnack
handled it decently well getting the
rook to g6 and Bishop c4 it's uh it's
still back seam on the con the clock
right his opportunity to prove something
but the problem with the rook on g6
everybody is is now h5 is an idea and
that was one of the things we mentioned
earlier of why you played aged four is
you're what Maxine was doing when he
played h4 was preventing the traditional
idea for this rook lift to come to g6
because often you're just worried about
it you know getting trapped over here
but now now grishnack has committed it
I'm just feeling very nervous with only
eight minutes on the clock fifteen moves
to make before time control this is
gonna be a very difficult position for a
black what if I just play a simple move
like rook up to here Robert I'm still
threatening f7 I'm threatening h5 how
does black deal with that
probably Brooklyn trolled the first
ranked rookie one check is pretty tough
to meet and the night of g5 is stuck for
the time being because they have seven
pawn
yes it's under attack but then you lose
the g3 pawn so seems like tactically Guk
is hanging in there barely early he is y
can play like Bishop d2 hun rook da stop
rook d1 I'm still threatening h5 but
you're no longer threatening mate takes
f7
uh-huh because doing so would allow rook
takes d2 at the end of that line
everybody that's Roberts that's Roberts
point in addition to the fact that g3
might be hanging
so Bishop Bishop c4 then let's let's
consider what other candidate moves
maxime might be thinking of
I obviously don't want to move the rook
off of the F file back to the D file I
would say in theory because the whole
point was to win the f7 pawn but now
that the rooks on g6 and there's threats
of h5 I wonder if there's something to
that maybe rook d1 is a candidate move I
like your work have to move I just I'm
struggling to see the aftermath of rook
b8 yeah so but what if you just played
like okay no Bhishma for now I don't
think so
maybe you're better be to move is good
but then rook to d5 Oh 85 I'm hanging up
seven oh no no I'm not hanging up seven
that's actually crazy i blundered but i
made a blunder in return because night
six of seven then I have rook takes D so
anyway right away yeah at the point
everybody's you're overwhelming the
defense and this would be a position
where the two miners would serve very
well against the rook because we don't
have a spawns on them open side open
sides of the board the pieces are
actually very quick to coordinate here
and start working together and
blockading some of these light squares
so that's exactly the kind of dynamic
where the rook gets crushed by the two
miners completely under that by the way
I was fortunate hey I'm blundering my
way into into borderline lost positions
all the time so yes sometimes we all
need to fill up words we all fail up but
alright Bishop c4 on the board the other
the other thing that's had some clarity
added to it is the game between Dingley
run and a nice Giri
let's uh let's back things up and head
over there we've got Knight to d3 now on
the board but the point is that Giri
established this a4 idea we've been
highlighting for a while as blacks
blacks kind of key point to not just get
positionally pounced wear white
dominates the dark squares and with it
the bad C pawn you play a4 which is a
sacrifice temporarily but your hope is
that you will regain the pawn and with
it have kind of cured some of the some
of the elements of this C pawn by
removing the beep on here maybe you can
get them get a passed pawn going so this
is this is kind of the idea and now
we're getting the Queen's off the board
and and here we stay it you're Robert
well I love this position for why it's
an endgame where only he can press but
can we go back to when white played
Bishop to f3 because I want to highlight
that move a little bit more as honestly
one of the moves of the round if not V
moving around but one that is so subtle
that most people wouldn't even blink
when they see it and the reason why is
what Isaac Dingley red 100% and that
kind of precise move is required to turn
slight edges into serious ones and
that nagging village into a win and the
reason I never win these games the
reason I love Bishop f3 is because we
kept talking about how if white up a
knight d3 instead of Bhishma 3 now cream
is coming over to g4 over to h5 becoming
a threatening piece a menacing piece on
the kingside so web playing Bishop f3
you are being pre-emptive you're saying
okay now I really am threatening Knight
to d3 and once I play Knight e3 your
queen can't start attacking me it has to
retreat and now that I have you on the
back foot I'm going to go all-in on the
c5 square so show something if this
happened and the Queen moves everybody
this is exactly the kind of game that
white just starts to grind away
positionally okay go ahead for sure and
so it's sort of forced anisha's hand to
play move like a 4 because you don't
want to be sit pal e and just be
defending computers can do that humans
struggle with that because we don't like
sitting position in positions where we
must shuffle back and forth we want a
concrete plant it plays a 4 but the
downside is exactly what we're seeing in
the game and as we go to the
continuation all these moves were more
or less forced and expected by these
players
White has an outside passed pawn this
pond can go 284 which protected by a
knight on c5 we look at the quality of
the pieces the bishop on d7 is stuck
passive the knight on c5 is better than
I don't have six the knight effect isn't
bad and White has the 8 B and C files to
work with where black even if you put a
second work on a 8 at some point not
really doing much because I'm my palm
being a 4 and ice protected by a minor
piece so the quality of the pieces here
clearly favors white and already there
are some tax code more motives we're
like let's say you go rook a5 over
that's ok fine I know you were gonna say
Brooke a7 but the point is if takes
takes with the knight you have bishop
takes d5 and the pawn is pinned of
course yes well I could take with the
rook but you know in this position still
the robbers is pointing out that there's
other tactical issues here as well yeah
exactly
I'm feeling you I mean and again it's
it's it's a quick to result position and
we highlighted or I kind of said
remembering the last two times last last
time these two guys met were doing me
had the white pieces against a nice giri
and at the sink fell Cup in 2019
it just felt eerily reminiscent of of a
game that was unclear but once once ding
li Ren got that chewed result position
he grinded it out I believe even
Kasparov said it might have been the the
finest game ding li Ren had ultimately
on his way to winning that event of
course playing Magnus Carlsen in the
tiebreaker and beating him but yeah this
this is looking looking nice and very
very tough for black I mean
pawns being on the light squares also
favors white long-term positionally okay
defending the position still possible
how would you do it is black let's say
you would go for Brooke a7 you try for
King f8 Keaney 17 d6 you know if you can
if you can establish that kind of plan
before white gets something going you
maybe have a chance to hold but it's
definitely gonna be one where white is
white is holding all the cards now so
yeah I'm gonna play for pretty much no
matter what and then I can decide do I
want to pull my bishop on d1 or am I
happy leaving it on f3 am I gonna go
over a2 b1 and try to take over the B
file if you allow me or are you gonna go
over b8 or something like that but then
you give up control over the C file so I
love rook a B would by the way I love
when you talk about rooks on the open
files it's either I put my rook behind
my past pawn which is one good rook or
am i broken an open file which is
another good rook and black is just
really struggling it doesn't have any
space in the position and it's not that
this position is winning because
objectively it certainly is not you give
this to an engine I'm sure they tell you
that they'll hold without too much
difficulty but the practical elements
are such that black has no concrete
aggressive active plan and every single
idea that you do come up with a for
black has some serious concession that
you have to be concerned about I love
what Dingley red is doing here he's
setting himself up for a second
consecutive victory and if he is able to
win this game oh boy a man on a mission
yep and and you know you mentioned
Fabiano Caruana having some great
positions maybe because of prep but not
converting sometimes being on the wrong
foot to start can maybe help you find
your form faster right we know that when
players get a bad position then you have
to kind of you know kind of muscle up so
to speak as a chess player and how
calculate your opponents to save games
that can pay dividends down the road
right Robert you and I have shared
personal stories I think we both had
similar experiences I remember a couple
of times tournaments I won the first
round of the event was an event that I
almost lost right to maybe a much lower
rated player right just didn't play well
got myself in a terrible spot and the
fact that that round had me kind of on
the edge almost in hindsight you look
back you're like maybe that's why I
played well this whole tournament right
because I started off there what are
your thoughts on some of that that the
psychology of starting off on the wrong
foot but maybe Dingley been finding
himself as the event goes on well I
would say that in those kind of
situations you feel like there's nothing
to lose but not on the canvas
you know it's your shot at playing
Magnus Carlsen for the world
championship so there is always going to
be that pressure but once you get that
first victory you start feeling okay I
can do this
so while Bing obviously had a terrible
start two straight losses is not how
anybody envisions a good time but he
lost those two games then he comes back
he's facing a third consecutive defeat
it feels like he's really about to go
down in flames because five in a car one
on corks and novelty move nine is being
very aggressive and making Dingley I
think move after move but they proved to
himself in the entire world that Bingley
Ren is here he's back hopefully for his
sake to stay because he's found his form
in that game he was against it you know
he was against the wall back against the
wall he survived and he won and now he's
in this second position where again it's
not that this current position is
anything overly spectacular but it's so
frustrating to defend a position like
this move after move after move after
move and for a niche he showed good
defense against Wang Hao couple rounds
ago but this is a totally different
style of position where it's I mean to
me it's so unpleasant and I might be
overstating it a little bit just because
of my clear proclivity for positions
there you know have activity have
different plans but you know it doesn't
feel good to have this position from the
black community five times fast no thank
you
okay but I am gonna make you say
something that defends our opinion of
the fact that night takes b3 was a
no-brainer by weighing out Wang Hao
right well apparently not he took with
the pawn we gotta go back to this game
I'm not happy about that and okay that
was my first thought too I was spying it
as you were talking about Dingley rent
finding his form and I think that one of
the points Robert is that he might have
calculated very concretely that the b7
pawn is just gonna fall in some of these
line I was looking at it and I'm
thinking you take with the rook and
you're gonna bring the rook to a7 and
the fact that you get rook a 7 and
Bishop a 3
so I'm with you obviously I think that I
think that night takes be three was was
the kind of the no-brainer choice right
you're hitting the rook and then you
only open file but maybe he's concretely
saying that he thinks this game is
closer to converting than we thought I
mean you take on a one you come to a
seven how does black defend the b-pawn
in some of these critical wines rook to
b8 okay the only thing I see so rook
takes a one I I'm assuming now although
last time we assumed maybe he'll take
with the bishop looking at I mean but
let's say Brooke takes a one okay group
so that's been Knight b6 so ignore okay
and if I play Brooke a7 you're giving me
the b7 phone no no I'm gonna go over b8
now okay and I played Bishop III you're
gonna play e6 no I'll put Bishop of fate
start with the bishop retreat I don't
need to be six for playing Knight e5 up
dude I'm about to grind you ever hear of
Jamie Foxx slow jams I'm not too slow
jam this one all over you
Knight c8
and then I'm going to offer you a draw
and you're probably going to accept
Brook a fortnight b6r okay Brooke at
seven thanks a little tickle huh
something like that
No also also with my nan b6 there are
moments where I can just play rook e8
and trade the ropes off the board
because ya bish 183 that is true
okay there's lines like there's lines
where the b6 night falls at the end but
but I don't think whites in any real
shape to win a game like this yep
Wow okay and if we go back to this you
know the start of this yeah raising take
with the pause the real reason I don't
like it is look at the night on d2 and
see how many options it has once a takes
b3 happens all right that nights not
going anywhere
it actually has not a single good square
to go to but then a b3 that thing can
hop around a little bit maybe go into c5
it supports an a4 a5 type push so that's
how I like to see chess on see you know
sometimes I miss details because I'm
looking at the big picture and not at
the granular stuff but I'm always
thinking about how can I improve my
pieces where do they belong and I can
assure you the night does not belong on
d2 in an end game like this what's it's
not a bad way to think at all I think
it's kind of a very simple criteria just
the move I'm about to play give my
pieces more squares or less squares
right people talk about that as a very
basic criteria to justify a sacrifice
how do you evaluate the initiative right
are the moves I'm making opening up more
or less options just a very simple kind
of checklist right so I'm defending the
way you think about chess Robert I mean
it makes sense okay interesting decision
a takes b3 played obviously nothing
really to speak about in terms of the
clocks these players within five minutes
each other kind of the opposite
storyline in terms of the clock being a
factor in this game between Mexican
bhushaiah The Grove and Alexander
griffix so let's go back to that Maxime
has still not moved after Bishop to c4
so using his time advantage but with
only eight minutes for another 15 moves
I think this one's gonna give us
fireworks here before before time
control was reached
yeah I'm actually just seeing Wesley so
in the game check of this game and the
calmness of him was not what about chess
but it was funny he said life is so much
better with the block button
[Laughter]
Wesley Wesley to his credit has has a
lot of fun with the chest comm members I
mean often engaging and you know I want
the things that we can't really discuss
on live shows that they have a lot of
fun talking about stuff but but maybe
every once in a while it's nice to block
somebody who's trolling him we get it
Wesley he'll be joining us by the way at
some point Wesley so is scheduled to be
a guest commentator for those of you
who've been watching our coverage
throughout throughout the beginning of
this event here thank you so much for
being with us we've had a Cara Nakamura
vishwanath on andand we've got the one
and only robert hess where it is baby
blues and Wesley so among others will
also be joining us you and Daniel
narrowed its key have been doing a
fantastic job and to more than let's see
looking at different platforms here more
than 12,000 of you with us thanks for
being with us all the chats are rolling
along that's how we know you're having a
good time giving us given us hellos in
the chat rooms thanks for being here
yeah I just gave Wes a hello in the game
chat and he said early morning wake up
show so we got like the early morning
show
yeah I'm glad that you know the first
thing he's doing is looking at some
chess and tuning in but you know
basically has a block button for the
chest comp Evers I bet you wish you had
a block button for your co-commentator
sometimes I wish I could do that that we
have on screen right now is exactly what
I would like sometimes you you had a lot
of other people buddy I hear you know
it's Danny sometimes I wish I could just
make a vish that was I cannot wait until
visi comes back so I can throw that one
at him Danny red spot on that I did that
was ridiculous
quickly quickly looking at the game
between yonder pamba Yoshi sorry father
no Caruana playing with the white pieces
should be mentioned first and Jana pond
Miyagi not not a lot changing other than
the fact that it's kind of like we said
it's it's good defense from black right
the the geometry of the Queen and Bishop
is kind of ideal here everybody because
you blockade the d6 square you still
keep an eye on not just h6 but also
potentially this g7 square would be very
careful so so the the blockade is ideal
Robert but but why does
control right at some point you wonder
is there a way to execute pressure here
you'd love to have an idea where you
quickly flip to this long a 1h a
diagonal with mating nets we've been
talking about that for a while but I you
know I don't know I mean it's just gonna
be one that always looks like white was
better start to finish but ultimately
yields nothing
I think this she was the one who came up
with this idea of Queen before and now
they look at this position what I expect
black to do is Queen d6 Queen before
Queen a3
just keep moving the Queen work and
offer a trade as long as you're not you
know blend or anything that don't do
that but let's say go Queen d6 here how
you gonna react to that move yeah you're
hitting defy yep well that's what I was
highlighting in the geometry is is more
or less perfect here for black to defend
and hold everything you need to but okay
I'll take the bait let's say you play
Queen d6 I'll play Queen c4 I'll try to
sit sit tight here you sitting tight Wow
what's happened to you you've changed in
the course of this comments I've been
I've been watching a lot of chess
coverage by these guys they are disky
and Hesse and Anand over the last been
waking up in my early morning and and
learning some learning a thing or two so
what if I wanted to be voting before
maybe I'd go Queen c6 yeah I don't want
to lie your queen in like that so I'm
gonna start with nah I mean I can't make
it work what I want to do is go Queen g5
at some point you're gonna go g3 just to
avoid all these checks is I think you
will at least right you know I was
trying to make g5 happen but as I
learned from Mean Girls sometimes you
can't make fetch happen it's very risky
to play g5 it's kind of move you also
you often beg to take back but again
this is not my game so I'm gonna play g5
I'm gonna try to win your h6 pawn and
then if I if I lose I'll take it back
and we'll start again let's head over to
the Dingley run a game with a nice giri
getting a great comment from a a long
time diamond member big fan over the
chest TV chat Steph 9 for the reason the
tactic didn't work with the rook on a5
is the Brooke actually guards d5 so
there was no Knight takes D 7 and Bishop
d5 when the rook can take it so the idea
is there and it you have to keep an eye
on it sometimes there's this Bishop g4
thing that maybe was a tactic to watch
out for but rook a 5 was actually a nice
defensive square from Geary and but I
still think everything Robert said is
chuh a force perfect not just because of
the a pawn rushing yes yes we could try
to undo the blockade but I think now
rook a b-1 is a serious threat now that
the a pawn is defended right there's no
rook takes a - if you give white one
move that move is rook a to be 1
followed by either entry to b7 or b6 and
Geary has a lot of problems to solve
here he does and the another issue is
that playing rooked eight rook c8 8 that
is you're teaming up on the 8th pawned
that is protected by the less valuable
piece so you know you're doubling
unfiled that'd be good if it only the
rook or on a1 protecting the palm but
there's also the night there so I do
feel like the position remains as we
left it easier to play for white but
let's talk strategy
Dany and this is a genuine question if
you are playing this from from the black
side with any tier II what pieces do you
want to trade
I think you want to somehow force me to
play Knight takes D seven yeah because
then my a for pawn is weaker and that
Knight can just go from color complex to
color complex take everything off the
board I would actually love to take all
the minor pieces off the board is black
I think I have the best drawing chances
at a rook ending right yep
so the question then becomes how in the
world you make that happen and I don't
say I ask the king of a king e7 King be
sixes okay if you go all the way to d6
there may be a fork town waiting for you
be careful but the point is I mean there
is some ways to maybe try to prove this
position you know you King bring the
King up maybe you put the bishop on EA
to try to get 97 in some positions
Robert that's an idea because you know
if you can try to force the trade of the
knight on c5 but there's probably
tactical consequences so it's easier for
us to kind of you know superficially say
oh here's some defensive ways to put put
the pieces but making that happen
concretely it's gonna be a whole nother
a whole nother question
shout out to chess Brainiac diamond
remember loving the commentary keep the
questions coming in chess TV everybody
we see you and thank you for being
active in all the chat rooms people
talking about the game between MBL and
the grish ik saying that russian is back
on the clock which means he's going to
lose on time according to Wesley cell
he hasn't been moving he's under three
minutes left what's going on here yeah
two minutes and 20 seconds and counting
I'm so the danger here everybody brookie
one kind of it's partly an idea I was
trying to suggest even though I didn't
execute it well big surprise right but
the reason I didn't want rookie up to
because of Roberts great rookie eight is
I wanted to just make a simple move that
brings back the whole reason why rookie
six was supposed to be risky because now
I can play for H five and and I don't
even have to win the rook Robert my
point is if H five Brooke h6 even if I
just settle on although I might have
something cuz if I move the knight my
rook actually defends H five I might
have something like ninety four and
Bishop g5 but okay my ponies even if I
just settle on defending you know that's
the whole point of this Berlin structure
for whities you've got this two-on-one
now on the outside of the board it's
very dangerous for black you also in
those sort of lines with the community
seven there east six opportunities for
white if you can time it right I'm I
like your age five move and after rook
age six then I was thinking about some
kind of e six but I I don't know because
I'm cutting off your Bishop from the f7
pawn oh my gosh have you been you know
do it your posit rush are you eating
your Wheaties buddy
I'm just three hours ahead of me in the
copy I should quite get did over here at
six a.m. on the west coast
I've been compensating with Vishy Anand
for several days and that forces you to
be energy in my face I wanted to be here
for the last three days and I couldn't
be here and that was just me explaining
why I've been trying to be as sharp as
possible but now you're bringing me back
down that's that's what's happening here
is a great move jokes aside every but
the point is that Bishop takes Roberts
ideas the bishop is pinned
so Brooke takes f7 as lights out
obviously taking with the pawn probably
still Brooke f7 is super strong
one crazy move might be like rook takes
h5 you get away with it but probably not
rook takes f7 I'm sure it's just just
super dangerous so what could possibly
be the move on King e7 h5 work age six
and six you might have played f6 but the
reason why here it looks good for white
is I was single Knight f3 lose the
attack on your bit too with my bishop
let's see one hitting you Brooke on age
six and the plain ith 496 checkers Oh Oh
feels good but what if you play rook h7
instead of I don't know this is okay
seven instead of what or rook h8 walks
right into that fork right but rook h7
9h for your pointy he's not a fork can
you take on e6 just this would be the
kind of thing that if you can figure out
under time pressure and VL might just
tip his hat and say good job but this is
gonna be so tricky with two and a half
minutes trying to solve all these
tactics you just you know we've
highlighted it's the storyline people
talk about all the time right Alexander
getting himself under time pressure is
it's ill-advised right it's sometimes it
leads to having great blitz kills he is
a former world blitz champion someone
who has does very well every year on our
own speeches championship we know that
but but in long time control games time
pressure is is nobody's friend
certainly and look how much time Maxime
has hey the thing is if you can figure
out that is h5e six move order doesn't
risk too much where you always see some
sort of bailout you a hundred percent
have to go for it
considering Engrish cooks time right now
because if you do allow question if you
get two moves no free moves then all of
a sudden you coordinate you're feeling
okay with yourself you know if black can
play Bishop back to e6 for instance
stopping any sort of ePHI v6 push then
whatever advantage you hope to have will
no longer be there let's remind
everybody obviously the pressure right
now the black is facing on the kingside
has our attention h5 may be coming but
if we remind everybody of how we got
here it started with this sort of
positional gambit back on move fifteen
if you will white laughing in the face
of danger and ultimately going for these
lines where the pawns are broken on both
sides of the board and you're losing one
of them because of it so if black can
hold you know despite the time pressure
that's Roberts point he is up upon this
is for MBL to prove prove the sacrifice
and idea I've got a crazy way to try to
prove it if I could get something like a
four and Bishop a three I mean again a
lot of you to sacrifice pawns that are
mine but it's it's not a bad idea
and you can do that without psychic
resume going Bishop d2 vision be fun
right yeah I like your idea and actually
in the sequence we've been discussing
with h5 you know this Hawaii HIV six
configuration you might even throw that
move in actually let's look at that h5
or okay 6 e six I think you have to go F
6 ft 6 in Knight f3 rook age 7
I think this sequence is for us and then
you're not actually threatening Bishop
takes c6 now because I have Knight to d4
by playing Knight age 4 I've actually
gotten rid of my response to Bishop
takes c6 so what did I play your move
Bishop d2 or 8 bit should be 2 here
yeah there's and there's also I mean
there was a for there's also Bishop f4
in some positions to try to go for c7
[Music]
like it's holding and maybe even a
little better up upon if he could figure
out everything but it's very very
dangerous yeah I would not like to play
this position
can't sign me up for this one with two
minutes on my clock no way up okay a lot
of the games heating up by the way if
you're just tuning in we have no results
yet in round four of the 2020 feed a
candidates tournament thanks for being
with us here on chest outcome and remind
you of what it's all about Alfie why are
we here
well someone's got a challenge magnus
carlsen at the end of this year and into
within two weeks we're gonna know who
that person is and and the storyline
becomes clear but by the way h5g for
played quickly that was kind of the
initial idea we talked about before you
found this this aggressive east six
which while very sharp and rather
brilliant right especially in these
lines that we were showing in the end
because of f6 has a response Robert
maybe e6 was a little bit rushed so back
to just h5 and g4 you've got this two on
one now which is a strange two on one I
think for people to see optically at
first right you think of two own ones
differently but this is a this is an
outside edge pawn that happens in these
Berlin structures black has to be
careful about I love this approach from
Maxime especially when your opponent's
in our time pressure you don't go for
these forcing lines now he's thrown out
now it's just so tough for black to
figure out the right move I'm playing
Bishop e6 and doing it yes early yeah if
you do Bishop e6 what what is the what
are the chances that my H pawn is enough
to compensate for the Queen side pawns
I've sacrifice I don't know if that
means I take but I'm trying to say like
if I go for some lines like Knight takes
c6 you have to take with the rook and I
don't know I mean I have Bishop g5 check
but I kind of wanted to just say you
know with all the pressure I have can I
go for Russian hairy up the board you
know I feel like you can't just because
you hear g6 might be the move to stop
your H pawn from that could be a very
good move actually okay so let's say
instead we go for the maybe five check
or something yeah honestly didn't think
about that move so that's on me King f8
I think I must have to rock everyone I'm
gonna go King g8 oh this is getting so
spicy right you're given up f7
but five is hanging if you take f7 yeah
mission one g5 under attack only I was a
minute and 40 seconds so sometimes we
have questions when we're covering over
the board tournament games like this
where to focus when there's so much time
on the clock we don't know where the
where the fireworks will happen but I
have a feeling we should probably stick
right here with grishnack under so much
time pressure
that's our bird's-eye view if you're my
if you're trying to remind yourself
where you can watch those things over at
chess calm slash events or chess calm
slash live choose-your-own-adventure
head over there and pick a different
game by the way that Queen on d1 by
Fabiano renewing the threat of advancing
the d pond and and be careful there's
geometry the queen coming to g4 or f3
heading into f6 over on that board so if
i had to choose one other game I'm
looking at it's that one but but I think
we'll stay right here Robert yeah we
should certainly stay here well al is
integral shook in a minute and forty on
the clock I also agree with you that
that Fabiano Caruana game it can go
either way you know you play a little
bit too long in a position like this as
white and certain end games are not
going to be good for you and as I look
around there that elects anko exactly
what we were talking about with this
Knight b6 rook b8 it looks a little bit
passive but I think it's going to
suffice and then I really like King Lear
ends position that one has my attention
we are very different stylistically
Danny but I'm really curious how ding
Lauren's gonna work that he played
Bishop a d1 he's he's slow playing it so
it'll slow Jamz there but right now
Alexander Christina Sheila growled that
game deserves all of our attention and
Danny rook h8 was played rook aged 6 to
8 and how does it make you feel I know
what you to talk about the feelings you
feel I he found it very quickly I'll say
but it wasn't your Bishop e6 maybe
because he didn't like the idea of the
transition of the two-on-one the game
the move doesn't make me feel any
different in the sense that Mac seems in
control Grichuk doesn't have a lot of
time with with 12 more moves to make
before before time control and we've run
out of time in and I'm being told we
need to take a very very
break its not going to be a long one so
don't go anywhere we're taking our break
now because we expect to be with you
probably toward the toward the time
pressure action here as the first
segment of things wraps up in all these
games so don't go anywhere when we come
back we're gonna focus on this time
scramble and all the other exciting
moments from round four of the Twenty
twenty feet a candidates we will return
in just a few
[Music]
you
and we are back as promised here with
the 2020 feat a candidates tournament
all four games in round four still
rocking and rolling here Robert we
haven't seen in the action in the game
that's had most of our excitement and
attention terrific now under two minutes
on the clock we have seen
a couple moves over here in the Wang Hao
Carrillo Alex Cinco game if you want to
talk a little bit about that looking
more and more like like Wang Hao should
have listened to Robert has taken with
the night yeah I don't think the
symmetry in the position for the pawn
structure that has favors him there one
thing that black needs to be careful
about well the two things one of the b7
pawn gathers the d5 pawn currently but
black can play east six right now
protecting d5 and then bringing the King
towards the center reroute that Bishop
from g7 to fate it feels like there's
just no weaknesses to to just take
advantage of and pick on so I do think
that Kirilenko is defending this one and
will be fine in the remainder of this
game yeah shout out to uh Kwame coming
at us from one of the chat rooms I
forget which one asking how good Grichuk
is under time pressure well he's uh
wondering one of the best in the world
and he said he's a former world blitz
champion and someone who handles himself
well partly because he finds himself in
that position a lot and yeah so I mean
we don't know whether that's gonna be
the case here I think the big issue with
being under time pressure is if you're
also worse on the board that's a problem
right I think one of the things to
remember is that these guys are good
enough to play to play with literally
living off the increment if the position
is playable if they're better if they
understand the plan in a position where
you're also dealing with a lot of
pressure here from MBL White clearly has
a teeny bit I think of an edge if you
can find a way to convert on on this
outside majority here but the biggest
issue is is will he be worse on the
board also with having very little time
yeah I mean I keep burning back to ideas
that you mentioned with a for Bishop a3
check for white and trying to figure out
what blacks plan is exactly White has
that thread of Bishop a3 Chacko after a
fourth even go east six at some moment
so there are a lot of things happening
here and why does attack you from all
directions suddenly
I don't think there's less time let's
dive deeper into this game I think it's
the one that a lot of people want to
talk about not just because of the line
you're giving I actually see some people
discussing that exact line in chess TV
chat and 44s along with chess Brainiac
they're looking at a four-night a4
Bishop III black does have c5 to block
the check but but even that I mean this
is this looks bad rookie 4 here I was
gonna say Brooke e4 there's also still
your East 60th mentioning in 94 okay but
let's over key for it's just like a
skewer yeah b5 and I'm gonna take your
bishop on c4 and then take up 7 yep you
would do something as nests how do you
like blacks pawn structure now how you
like them apples right this actually
looks you take g7 necks and you just
start pushing your King side pawns okay
Wow eight board 90 X 8 port was played
actually incident I played it as part of
analysis but apparently it's exactly
what the relay has brought us here they
should be three check I'm expecting to
be played yes check c5 is there anything
else black and oh I think after rookie
for this line here Bishop e6 is like a
saving grace
I mean okay like you can still take here
and after ten get five you take c5 with
check yep King d7 and you think you have
two pieces for the rook but you're
saying you get rook h5 yeah and down
goes f5 very likely and you don't have
very many phones no kind of scary right
isn't there you six can i play like rook
g4 and then try to use my my e pawn but
just black have f6
baby fine but f5 is that weakness and
I'm just trying to yes don't think shuts
make sense it's a very close call
well either way and this is one of the
problems when you get under time
pressure is in theory if you're if the
game is still in these critical moments
whoever has more time than the clock
will find the better moves right in
theory right blunders happen even by the
best players in the world but if these
guys manage the situation well probably
Maxime is gonna figure out exactly what
the best line should be even more than
Robert and I can do an analysis and
that's that's the issue with with
griffix approach here like I said I know
I said it earlier and you reluctantly
agree with me I know you hate it to do
that but I think MBL is gonna convert
and and in hindsight we're gonna look at
this one it's a very well-prepared
Berlin from the Frenchman I think he's
gonna win this game actually even online
I keep it's funny I'm trying to give you
know the broader strokes analysis that
I'm like let's go into the specifics oh
there's Lana we keep looking at with a
three check yeah see five rookie for
Bishop e6 I can even just take on e6 by
the way I'll never mind your ideas I
thought maybe we could do your same idea
but do Brooke f4 to avoid Bishop e6 a
temple but then it doesn't work as b5
you can't sacrifice and take up sevenths
of death right so you got to put a
bookie for Bishop e6 just take the
bishop take the bishop I guess if King
takes you win a piece obviously and if
pawn takes I assume you're playing
Brooke g5 with tempo yep took the
highlights right out of your mouth there
you did sometimes the simplest solution
is the correct solution and I was so
busy focused on these tactical ideas and
we'll just take the bishop go rook g5
two pieces under attack at the same time
G and H pawns running really fast
it looks so tough first Sasha here yeah
and again this is this is where the
where the the Berlin can be at its best
for white here we go with Bishop III
check so you know again it is sort of
the punchline of top GM chess and and
kind of has been for a very long time as
it became known as a very very solid
rolling weapon as black but there's a
reason
guys like MBL who prepare as hard as
anybody and go deeply into this stuff
there's a reason they're willing to
continue to come back to it and if you
can if you can trick your opponent in
some variation where maybe you
understand that stand it better I mean
we
came back here on mu 17 with g4 that by
itself was not a novelty you talked
about the Nakamura Giri game from Zagreb
last year but but the whole aggressive
idea that that he took with this H pawn
sacrificing c3 to mobilize this outside
you know two on one with the with the H
and G pull and also the pressure on the
F file with only a minute on the clock I
don't want to go anywhere else because
guess what Grichuk has to find the key
move here right I think if c5 is met
quickly with rookie four we could be
looking at our first decisive game of
the realm yeah I think this is the game
for Maxime to win and Danny I was about
to say that this is the type of game
along with many other reasons that I'm
not 2700 because the amount of times
I've done exactly cool he played he six
that that's surprising but it was your
initial take and just taking on c5 and
doing all this stuff but okay
but I was going to say that they're
moving very quickly now as Chris Rock
has no time but stealing a pawn hoping
that it works out sort of speculative
and then getting in huge time trouble so
you have no time to calculate in
critical moments that has been a fatal
flaw of mine for many years and right
now Gris shucks it's vintage cook and
he's obviously a far superior player
compared to me but he's having that
situation where these are really crazy
tactics and he has to look at so many
different things that II six move I'm
not positive about but I trust Maxime he
knows what he's doing and Bishop takes
c5 and just go rook takes on c5 and hit
to c4 Bishop of the c7 pawn it should
weigh in let's look at it he's giving up
g5 cuz he gets c7 with check and only
then takes c4 this must be the idea
and somehow this doesn't feel I agree is
that the brook ending would not be my
first choice if I'm trying to convert
the W just on the principle of the manor
I know and that certainly White's the
only one who can win that but is there
something else here
after f6 that he's about to uncork that
we don't see
I don't know I mean I'm I'm with you I
think e six might have been a little
impatient and possible he there's no way
he didn't see your idea I mean the
reason rookie four was so strong
everyone from Hess's that b5 was not
possible because of this brilliant
exchange sacrifice and I mean Black is
just completely crushed here no matter
where you go I don't even know what
moves to recommend but the King moves
you can start gobbling pawns you have 96
coming this position is over so so this
was the key point
maxime instead very quickly plays east
six after c5 and that's the one thing
that could backfire if you're not hey
wait oh hey he's moved so we're gonna go
with it he's played Bishop takes we're
gonna get that exact line I think I
predicted everything by five can black
by c6 here go four more say well you
know you take that c4 now I just take on
g5 and I'm not giving you my C pawn I
think that seemed let have just let this
slip oh that's no seven though
but now let's go fishing take c6 like
tank e6 yeah give up the exchange I've
got a lot of pollens over here yeah this
this looks holdable now
think you know what I was gonna say is
the one thing that can that could be
sort of slippery when your opponents in
our time pressure is you want to win
right on the clock and so sometimes
you've rushed those moves to put them
under pressure okay he doesn't go for it
he's clearly gonna head to the
briquetting we already analyzed a few
minutes ago take c7 and then take c4 but
but I wonder if maxime rush d6 a little
bit I think he did and I don't think
he's gonna win this game
Wow you sure yeah because the line that
we were just looking with rook c7 takes
c4 I mean it's even material and the e6
pawn is a great strength in that it's a
very far advanced past pawn but it's
also a weakness in the sense that white
needs to be tied down to it and then
black comes got 85 84 83 and try to get
rid of that yep and distract and also
Danny we should point out long-term
theme if you trade off the a and B pawns
and loser g5 pawn for the see any pawns
still a draw that favor ethically is a
drawing position so well if you can
visualize it
use your imagination imagine only the
blue pawns I've highlighted left on the
board that's that should be an easily
drawn rook ending in borderline
borderline of drawing King and pawn
ending in some cases right I mean that's
one of those rare cases where you have
to be really careful you can't win
despite an extra Pesce and that's
disappointing
well I'm with you I think that I think
that e six was rushed I think that
unless there's something we were
misunderstanding about the difficulty of
the I think the last thing is the King
in the center right you look at it
Robert and wonder you know is there some
sort of checks just to highlight a fun
line to show everybody if you walk your
King all the way over to f6 it'll be the
last square you visit right fun little
fun little factoid put your pocket
so they're they're you know they're the
King is in a little bit of danger and if
the King has to run this way you know
then you've cut him off you have the e
pawn so that would be the last thing I
would I would say is maybe a an issue
for black but otherwise total agreement
we are in thanks Yoda yeah I'm still so
shocked that he's played ease X to be
honest and now he's spending too
see this is the thing that I don't
comprehend in incredible moments where
these top players amazing they're
they're fantastic will never question
that but they make a couple quick moves
and then now when it's the more obvious
part they're spending time which to me
is always always always a bad sign no
crook doesn't have much time so what
Maxime is probably doing is he knows he
single rook takes c7 rook takes d4 yeah
but he might try to have a couple quick
responses ready to keep that pressure on
the clock
however I would have much prefer he
spent time before rushing with a six
because now I don't think he has the
advantage he once did and I do believe
that rookie four idea was just
dominating I agree let's let's show it
one more time I mean I think you're
you're you're humbly not not trying to
to be over critical of these guys
they're twenty hundred I get it but I
actually think you have a very good feel
for what's going on here I think that
it's just clearly time mismanagement as
we're clearly gonna be joined by Vichy
and on here in just a second as we see
him on camera there in the background
one second so I think I think I think
you actually have a pretty good feel for
it you know in the sense that East six
was clearly rushed I mean I think any
time at any levels when you see someone
make a few obvious moves there and then
all of a sudden pause ten seconds they
might have miscalculated something
although we do have a a world champion
with us now so maybe Vichy can add some
clarity we were looking at this position
Maxime seen moments away from converting
a very well-prepared Berlin Vichy but
then instead of rookie four he plays
this move east six and were immediately
questioning whether this rook ending is
gonna have enough winning chances to be
honest I prefer rookie phone as well
because I thought but maybe then nobody
should be six I take a fee six g5 it's
still pretty unpleasant
yeah and that was an exact one we
actually looked at yeah yeah plus I
could actually take on a four in a
bishop si I can see if I would check in
to achieve I mean I can't believe this
completely but let's see what he did
twenty-six
EPS six
Bishop c5 check yep maxie by Roxy in
fact he played fg5 I thought this idea
was c6 yeah yeah you liked the exchange
stack Robert liked it too
I thought what he intended was rook
takes c4 f g5 wrote back to c5 ah ok I I
assumed that was what he was aiming for
but I felt that blacks should be able to
do something with g6 maybe yeah g6 was a
really nice move yeah or maybe rook F 8
and then Duke hit 7 and then took f6
somehow crawling out a bit and I was
quite surprised that Chris chuckle arute
c7 check maybe he's happy with the
ending but it seems a pleasant to me
what is he going to do after up Texas 7
King Day six weeks ago
Minh our point was it still maybe didn't
look as good as what white could have
got with rookie four but but you're
right I mean they so the king is in
danger you you're still giving white
some decent winning chances here
sure yeah I was thinking just 85 and
trying to rush that a pawn down the
board as quickly as possible sounds
that's probably what he's going to do
but you know this King is gonna wander
all over the place and if I can take g7
and g5
I might not even care about this pawn I
mean I can go Rudy for change right so
let's say by the way this position is
now on the board so let's say if a five
is for Brooke T for Chuck and the best
square I see c6 right anything else if
you go to this seventh rank maybe I play
Brooke d5 or something or actually
notice rook d7 take stuff okay you get
the other one so a5 it's been played now
by the way
[Music]
Brook
eat three I agree if I was probably the
best chance and maybe this is what he's
hoping from
so rookie 3 is interesting your idea is
you're gonna you're gonna rickroll me to
the Kings tip it to the edge of the
board well I want you to stop with
little D phone and then do it but yes
yeah I know that you okay so you like
rook d4 first king c6 and then rookie
three and you're gonna you're gonna roll
me over here yes
I mean maybe it'll catch e8 as possible
Brooke hej då Tori 8 sorry
actually sometimes my lips are good I
promise it wasn't a bounce lip I'm
actually slightly hard of hearing so I
wasn't sure which one it was but okay
maybe baby would be a better no but here
it seems that it's white doesn't have
enough squares to coral.you completely
right maybe this is acceptable but then
[Music]
oops maxime could have taken from c4 and
then gone c6 look sake fiber that wasn't
that didn't seem so big to me and just
wondering what maybe maxim wanted c6 9
th
but anyway so why don't we know this
actually is it's a good moment just to
take a pause that I saw Wesley in the
chat if we go back before Bishop III
check was played so in that position
where we're looking at rookie for
actually even after Bishop a3 away
three check c5 rookie for the trick is
that there's Bishop e6 and after 96 f e6
rook g5 there's Knight c3 which I also
overlooked because I was talking about
this position apparently black is doing
okay yeah the point everybody instead of
rook takes g7 black has King f8 which is
a double attack on both the rook on g7
and the knight on e4 classic Wesley okay
but what if I do
rook a four and go for the two pieces
for the rook thing ah but then maybe
black is in fact with King D 700 k e8
and well there's also Brooke h5 right
and then I would have to play rocket
chief all know that might fizzle out
yeah yeah we looked in a line like this
and we thought black was maybe okay and
okay
okay so back to the Y position do you
think that I really liked your idea of
rookie three mate maybe another mouth
slip was better by me maybe rookie three
first is wait I can do I can do d1 check
rook e1 check oh if I take e6 are you
mating me no you have king of seven
seven
rubee seven and now you and now you're
brookie so now a four in this last and
and rookie seven you go look at seven
but that must be and then Brooke a seven
this has to be horrible right well we
take 8 GJ I just about bailout exactly
okay which I can check I go check and
Brooke takes a four yeah
and then I'll go check take the rook and
play see for my way oh my gosh I love it
no g6 doesn't work you know but you can
call out to throw at 66
okay so so wait you're saying in synergy
six rook age six was possible you can
still kind of get out yeah the dates and
the new book c6 and I think it okay